[Music]
we are live it is tuesday september 7th
it is h3 tv
what'd it do what'd it be
what is it
thank you shredder
thank you but we're good
thank you
today's episode is sponsored by mint
mobile and liquid iv
guys thank you everybody for being
here this is the fun episode people
the other ones are not funny this is
where we come to have a good old time
yeah i'm happy to say that we got the um
we got the last episode unblocked yes
indeed which has now crossed a million
views thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love oh my god the chat is
freaking out because we started early
today
according to who
according to our start time it was set
to one o'clock oh my god damn 12 51.
okay i'm sitting here annoyed
because i thought we were starting at 12
30. oh you said what time we starting i
said we'll start at 12 30. you didn't
say that of course i did i said 12 30
normal time so i was sitting here and
everyone's just dilly dallying i was
like what am i in the bizarre world
everyone's acting like we're not 20
minutes late
sorry
and now pulling up the receipts
sorry
go ahead pull it up i'm pulling it up
yeah pull it up i'll wait
which is fair enough where he goes
oh 12 30 well said it at one
because you're always late
i do do that sometimes i will admit
because we originally started doing
after darks at 12
and we were always late so i started
setting it to 12 30. but last night i
said what time do you want to start
tomorrow 12 30 how about one and you
said yep oh i thought you said 12 30.
you said yep to the one
i said yep i just said yep i didn't say
yep one find it pull it up somebody
pulled that [ __ ] up
it's like discord
read it read a verbatim uh did you find
it a.b
it says uh what time tomorrow is 12 30
okay one o'clock what do you think yup
okay well
okay a miscommunication for sure i
thought you just said 12 30. but here we
are early here we are and everybody's so
impressed okay that's good
but i was just saying i was just like
what is going on these guys they don't
care about they don't care
i'm sorry we care too much
too much well we're here we're here and
we're early
certified lover boys sorry
sorry
yeah you know we talked a lot about um
certified lover boy drake's new album
versus uh donda dunda dunda it seems
like the consensus is kanye won yeah it
seems that consensus i honestly i didn't
even bother listening to drake's new
album because it was all the whole
branding everything was just so corny i
was like i can't turn this on
really i thought the consensus was the
opposite i thought more people were
liking the drake really i've seen
nothing but hate for the drake album
personally but i mean it's all
subjective maybe it's just the circles
like if you look at the internet or if
you look at melon the noodle drop he
gave donda seven and drake got like a
three
so sure right
yeah you're kind of looking like a melon
today i'm i'm melanie i'm not on this
[ __ ] today ela made me
yeah you lost the heart she made me
shave off the heart and the goatee cause
she's like we're doing the new show
on sunday yeah i don't think so oh my
god she's still here
she's not here but she's still giving me
[ __ ]
we're doing the new show on sunday and
you should uh
put your best foot forward and i said
you're right
what do you think ian
about donda
drake yeah uh i tried to get through the
drake one it's just
it just melds together it's hard to
distinguish the songs i actually watched
um
a bit of i don't i'm not a big fan of
his but dj academics did a stream where
he had his um
he had his you could find that i got to
find that yeah someone linked that yeah
you know what i got i know that it is
well the one i'm thinking of yesterday
he had his chat vote on drake songs
versus kanye songs from the new albums
and kanye won 10-0 in his own chat and
drake watches those streams like he was
texting academics so he saw that wait
they were texting while it was happening
yeah apparently oh god
drake sitting in his 100 million dollar
how much does this house like 250
million dollar house
probably we can look it up because kanye
put the address online
yeah as if it wasn't readily available
by the way but anyway this his biggest
stand in the world
this is the funniest [ __ ] ever
biggest stan
uh this twitch streamer he was like
drake's number one [ __ ] all y'all top
five in the world is drake drake drake
drake and drake
well he did a listening party for the
much anticipated that part's in this too
and so here it is what top five you
smoking on kendrick
because my top five is drink drink drink
drink if we broke it
he literally passed the [ __ ] out on
stream
during
because my top five is drake drake he
fell asleep dude
and it's not a gag i was like this guy's
got to be kidding no it wasn't a gag he
was sleeping on stream for hours
it's awesome
so
i love that video i think that's a
testament to yeah that was one of the
funniest things man and people were
tuning in to like i think his views
probably went up when he was passed out
because everyone was talking about it
right
how good is that
oh but he's he's not going to sit here
and try to tell me what the straight
face that drake is better than kendrick
that's blasphemy right ian
i mean you know they kind of serve
different
markers no no no no no okay wow so
political
god
what's different like you're not gonna
hear
you know kendrick out at the
you know
the bars and things like that
or in abercrombie
okay well i don't know if that's
necessarily a hit against him because
he's not trying to make music for
abercrombie and finch i don't think he
was saying it as a hit though he's just
saying he's right like it's different uh
some different democratic different
demographics someone's going to make
abercrombie music somewhere right
it's a market i i don't think i think
you can still compare them though
as a side note i went to abercrombie
over the weekend the mirrors in there
are crazy in the dressing room you could
change your song your setting your
lights yeah i saw your thirst trap post
it was uh i was so intrigued by a pretty
smart branding i do i do find that real
that's cool it was a cool mirror but uh
av did a thirst strap at abercrombie i
hope this doesn't make you sound like a
douche
no you looked good you looked good thank
you thank you it was a good post god
bless oh can i tell you guys a story
about something oh by the way i want to
say at the top of the show guys call in
800 or no no no it's on the screen 808
hot meme call in we have screeners
standing by
guys what i'm going to try to give you
some focus today
to help with the calls
so if you have beef
or you need me to mediate a disagreement
maybe do a three-way call
give us a call at 808 hot meme and let's
see if we can resolve the issue could i
myself have always been a mediator
um and i think i can help
thank you thank you
so okay you guys want to hear a story
that happened over the weekend
it's the worst
it's the worst thing
yeah it's this it's the most disgusting
thing that's ever happened in my
presence
no way
okay wait okay so so you're doubting
that
we've done a lot of disgusting stuff
in all of that worse than the meat cake
last friday
bro it done the meat cake doesn't hold a
[ __ ] candle to what i'm looking
let's see what about the mayo cake
nothing compares oh okay okay i'm
intrigued okay are you ready
so
theodore two-year-old son
is in the process of potty training
and he's doing great he's doing really
good honestly
he like doesn't even wear a diaper
anymore he's wearing his underwear but
he's had trouble like
the pooping has has has been um
difficult for him okay i pooped my pants
who's that
al roker
oh poor owl
pooped his pants sorry sorry no it's
okay
so anyway um
so he
when he does poop successfully on the
toilet
um
we get really excited okay
and so
he did like three he did like a nuggie
he did one nug he pooped and we go yeah
theodore woo
get all excited he gets all happy and
then he went back he's like i gotta do
more poop and he goes back the third one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he goes back he
got got more poop so he goes back does a
third poop there's three
like nuggies in the toilet
and the third time he comes over and
we're like yeah theodore you know
we're about to go take it and flush it
this just happened but we're like
celebrating because we want to you know
positively reinforce his his pooping
sure of course and as we're celebrating
alfredo oh no oh no swoops in and eats a
whole oh
human [ __ ] of theodores this size show
me
like a whole human [ __ ]
and he's going back for seconds
and ela has to
wrestle out the second nug out of his
mouth
he destroyed it he bodied the whole nug
and then theodore notices and he starts
bawling he goes theodore or he goes
alfredo ate my poop alfredo ate my poop
oh he was crying yeah because he freaked
him out he's like i'm right away my poop
he's like where's my poop alfredo ate my
poop
so me and eli have been trying to
is fredo okay i mean no he's fine i
looked it up they said it's actually
safe it's fine
okay like they'll digest it normally and
he did he he he digested it double
digested he had a normal poop he didn't
puke or anything wait so he went in the
toilet and got it well he has a little
baby toilet a train a potty
it's a it's just a little potty like
yeah yeah yeah that he sits on in the
living room
and then when he goes potty we take it
to the bathroom and flush it together
right okay and so
yeah so he just nicked it out when we
were celebrating
and it was
well at first when we saw it
i i saw him eating something and i was
like there's no [ __ ] way so i watched
patiently to see and then he started
going back for seconds
and there was miss and there was a whole
turd missing dude and hila caught him
with the second turret in his mouth ah
this is sick alfredo
ate my poop
he literally ate the poo-poo oh yeah
he's gonna say that hate the poop yeah
no but he was fine actually but like
we've been i've been just like wow me
and that ila were like it's gonna take a
while for us to get over that one
alfredo i know it was you fredo i know
it was you fredo shredder's like i
didn't eat poop
ironically shredder doesn't eat poop but
his breath still smells worse yeah
that's a that's a that's a zinger that's
a good one right yeah that's it yeah it
was
so
got a little wave of nausea when you
said it was so disturbing so disturbing
so so so disturbing wow wow the chat's
going crazy
somebody said it's gross but not as
unusual as you'd think i mean yeah dogs
dogs are gross you like eating poop i
don't know
yeah i think the problem is that because
alfredo is a street dog and he has a lot
of trauma
right that he
he is eating habits are so odd like
you know the poor baby he he'll i know
he's hungry but he'll just sit and stare
at his food and he won't eat
and then sometimes he'll try to nick
stuff like that when nobody's looking
and he he's just got the scavenger die
mentality
and um he saw his opportunity and he
[ __ ] took it and then they eat the
poo poo there it is
but you know what that's what it is
still love them
i
that is really gross
i'm going to say the mayo cake is still
grosser that's they're bro there's no
[ __ ] way the mayo cake is grosser i
had like two i had like two full bites
of that [ __ ] it wasn't even bad you
think mayo is worse than [ __ ] then human
feces being eaten by a dog though as
opposed to it yeah
this dog sleeps in my bed and he ate my
sons right well i wouldn't let him lick
my face after that but
that's good what's the lick embargo you
know what i mean like how long do i wait
before this curse is i mean it's three
days dude yeah i was gonna say like 48
hours maybe yeah it's been 40 i'm
thinking a week bro
i'm thinking like a full-on i mean they
don't brush so
no oh
wow i uh he took a poop the next day and
i go theodore i got your poop back
it's pretty gross but honestly it's not
very good
i thought that story would tear the
house down it's gross don't get me wrong
i'm not trying to downplay it you're not
mentioning my story bro
i guess if i was there i was there for
the mayo cake i smelt that
um
i almost threw up like three times when
we did that so i'm saying i guess you
have a male thing have like a male thing
what about when i took a bath in it did
that disturb you
yeah that was gross too for some reason
i don't know what it was about the cake
i didn't think that was that i mean
there was a smell it filled the smell
was a big element it i ate it it was
kind of good right zach like chopped it
in amazing interesting it melted the
flavors melted it was an interesting
like it's a bold it's a bold
spice
profile it's a fusion food yeah
some pallets are not equipped for it
like that they call that american fusion
dan
i did eat i didn't eat the mayo cake but
i did eat we did the uh
laugh you lose contest and i ate the
pumpkin pie with mayo um
yeah it's just mail guys come on
all right so let's move on we've got a
lot to get to here today
having fun already you guys yeah fun
here here we
are oh man we got so many great videos
to watch
yeah i'm excited though this sunday is
the new show everybody
it's happening
this sunday we're getting everything
ready
it's going to be fun
amarath is accepting subs to write on
her forehead right now oh for real
yes indeed
zach did his daily amaranth this girl
like nobody i've ever met
damn let's see i mean i don't know it
feels kind of demeaning to pay to get
something written on her forehead like i
mean i love her we literally did that
yeah you did that
yeah it's for charity though oh oh jesus
dude bro we can't show this
you didn't show that did you ma i don't
know if ian switched to it
let's just go with no that was insanely
graphic bro
let's get the dogs off she was like in a
thong straddling like oh
that was insane bro
vin diesel what do you think about that
let's get out of here let's go
let's go have lunch
so no on the uh writing http now is the
time for all that damn it
uh
look how beautiful she is what we got
here scooby doo but every character is
james charles that sounds interesting
dude
this thing [ __ ] so here we go
scooby-doo
as uh voice acted by every character is
james charles
uh no dread it i don't need
notifications in what world do i need
notifications from reddit you'd have to
be insane [ __ ] no dude you crazy
oh my god all right here we go
oh you muted it no i didn't i know you
didn't read it
stupid yeah it's video players really
bad
from you now i'm gonna start it over
sorry
[Music]
guys a pretty fast driver i'm very
impatient i have places to go things to
see money to make people suck
[Applause]
oh my god really
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
shout out to i
healt
[Music]
it's one of the best things i've ever
seen i love that
would you watch that show maybe we could
greenlight something like a fall oh
a full
two minutes it kind of had that adult
swim animation style so maybe they'd be
i wonder if you need to license that at
all from well yeah you're using his his
audio this is a little spooky
that's good though
um oh this was interesting
a post or we should do this with ela
actually the height one we should have
our in-depth conversation you know this
was oh i guess it got a lot there was a
lot of debate internally about this
somebody did a height calculation
i'd love a 6-6 of course
based on this photo where we're doing
our alpha poses
very alpha
there's a lot of debate here but what
first of all how are you gonna do
okay so they say zach is six four yeah i
guess he's zach you're not six four are
you i'm six three okay it's close close
i appreciate the little extra bump but
not
dan are you 5 10
uh no i'm a little bit more than that
but what
really got me is i'm listed as 5 10 and
ian is listed as 6'2 and we're like the
exact same height well what i don't
understand is cameron's right not four
inches taller cameron is right next to
him at five ten i don't know why his ian
got that generous six too yeah and by
the way in red too like ian did you make
this no but you know this looks right to
me
you're right next to elo you're i mean i
guess you're a little bit taller than
hila
i mean no you're taller than me
i couldn't yeah that's a good solid
almost half a foot right there
you're 5 5 twelve five thirteen i'll
tell you
sam makes a joke that it's actually two
where she says i'm five foot twelve
yeah exactly that's that's that's pretty
astute
i can't believe how many people thought
i was short
a lot of people thought aby was a short
king i think it's because i wear like
extra large shirts betta or because
you're listed as taller than me too
though i just noticed yeah no dan is
like a little bit taller than me yeah oh
for real dan is like six i got like way
underway hold on somebody called out
your shoes a b
do you wear these to for the extra
height because someone said that
these are those are air forces air
forces
i have air forces sometimes i put them
on because look usually what i wear is
like
nothing right yeah but when i put on my
air forces i feel so [ __ ] tall bro
they're fly as [ __ ] dude
they're nice shoes i'm just saying it
gives you a lot of jump
dan is a little bit taller than me he's
six foot
i'm between 5 10 and 5 11.
uh-huh which one i would say 511 but
there's like this meme on tick tock that
if you were 5 11 you would just say
you're right
they're right
you're five well i mean you are like the
same height you're five take off your
shoes and then come step to my head
because you got like these fat
[ __ ] like high heels for women
platforms let's see those feet dude air
forces but i didn't know but amy's tall
he's not he's not a short king i thought
it was interesting how everyone thought
that but cameron got done dirty too
cameron you were a little bit upset
about how this came out you saying you
were 510 is that right
he said he's confused
yeah i agree i agree he was pretty
heated he yeah you were
like you're like we have to talk about
this i need to defend myself like come
on now
yeah it sounds like a beta
okay but okay so somebody sent this to
me but this isn't accurate because
there's a perspective here right some
people are standing further away from
the yeah and like zach is significantly
closer to the camera than let's say
olivia and myself
you know
interesting but then sam's they said sam
is 5'2
that was that was to me the probably the
biggest
miscalculation sam er how did you feel
about being diagnosed she's upstairs
she's upgrading
but she's you know running around the
office like bilbo
energy
yeah
sam said she's 5'4 if i'm not mistaken i
guess it wasn't that fast
maybe he always says i make him feel
short though
well zach does this thing where we're
taking that picture on fridays where he
stands next to me on purpose and i don't
don't stand by me that's why people
think i'm short because you're so damn
tall maybe that's what happened because
i'm next to him and i got like way
underestimated it's like well if he's
six four though i'm six three but i know
i know but like if they think you're six
four
then
like that's super tall right and you're
standing further back from him too right
but i'm glad they said i'm five eleven
point five i was like i'll take that
[ __ ] baby
what's your height
i like to think i'm 511 okay
how does that come out too for you guys
is set that ring trail so good height
yeah because i stood up like we're like
the same height no we're not okay
take off your shoes come stand next to
me
ask to ask right now bro let's go get up
there ask to ask right you're hesitating
i don't want to oh
i don't know why you're insecure about
your height i mean you're still like
five ten five eleven that's a good hype
yeah that's
above average people were saying we're
tall they said we're a tall crew
beta
what is the
average
average
american male height i'm not insecure in
my height i'm just insecure when i'm
five foot nine so we're all we're all
above the the media let's go ask to ask
bro right now baby you don't gotta be
insecure you're beautiful man i don't
know why yeah you're everybody sims for
you everyone talks about how like they
want thanks i'm not insecure but thank
you guys
i don't want to hear that kind of talk
all right
all right well anyway
uh
interesting analysis
um
oh wow this is cool canadian political
party leader blasts
a wet fart on tv
that sounds like a rudy giuliani move to
me
something rudy giuliani would do
i think he has
the sound but you have it isolated good
because as always what fart huh when did
rudy far oh this guy farting no no the
rudy fart when did rudy fart
it was during um
i think we yeah we watched a rudy fart
video let me uh
rudy oh yeah during the the voter fraud
hearing yeah remember he was like in the
courtroom hit me with the sound
bite oh
interesting
yeah that sounds pretty that sounds
pretty good apparently according to
donald or according to trump because
he's there's like tons of books about
trump now at this point and people
that rudy used to clear rooms with his
gas
really as a flatulent man
i love it such a mess but anyway here's
a canadian political leader blessed in
what ass something that's knocking in
any way injure somebody this is clearly
violence this is trump this is the goal
oh my goodness
are we sure it was him
dude i mean yeah
like in a lot of these four videos the
pause is
suspect but
you said you had it isolated right zach
no no the rudy one oh
careful here let's try again
listen let's analyze this analyze it if
you will
why did i
i did some mod things this is trump this
is the goal is when you throw a rock at
someone your goal is to hurt them to
injure them to mainly violence this is
trump this is the goal is hmm
he put some like emphasis on it
this is trump this is the goal is to me
it seems like he didn't miss a beat
i'm a little
i know i'm always the one doubting these
fart videos but i i am a little what are
you doubting that it was edited or that
there was uh no then it's just something
else something else some background
noise or something i got picked up on
the mic
yo
oh we have an interesting call-in
we got okay this is really interesting
this i love just so you know because
sometimes the call-ins take a long time
we're just about at our uh ad break time
so maybe okay so let me say so just let
me just say jake don't go anywhere
he just made a video about the demilio
family not paying him for his photos and
the demilio family threatening to sue
him i heard about this story oh i did
too so this is an exclusive scoop uh
from jake
can we also real quick to say hi to
amaranth she's watching us on her live
oh she is hi amaranth
is it safe for me to open your stream or
no
because i almost
i almost got domed for that one
we were gonna write something on your
face but uh
i got scared when i saw you throttling
by the way just because i see people um
shouting him out a lot this politician
his name is uh
i'm sorry i'm going to say it wrong um i
think it's
jack james you see breakfast jagmeet
sing
maybe it's jug meat bro i cannot believe
i made you gently mispronounced that
guys i know and i feel bad because i i
really like that guy actually he's he he
seems doesn't seem like he's really good
[Laughter]
but shout out to him i i don't believe i
know she's right oh okay she's writing a
pickle rick just for clarity wow her
views went up a lot oh my goodness
that's freaking hilarious
i don't think it's meant to be hilarious
dan i'm watching it now there's some
other objective here to this stream and
the comedy oh people said i said it
right
okay okay good
um okay guys you go stop watching amrat
and come back to my stream please
once i mentioned her her views went up
by like two or three thousand and that
and but they're still there
yo come on come back i'm
don't make me take my shirt off
get my ass out
she's waving back
she is no i just left
um
so
okay we're going to take this call this
is really interesting
don't wait did he leave it's gone
oh no it's here wait like like i said
we're at 30 so if we but it moved down
to a different rooms uh what does that
mean it moved down to the screening room
oh that means somebody's talking to them
again maybe sam's following up to get
some more info from them or something i
think she may have told him that we're
going to add break
okay okay cool yeah stay in the line all
right let's thank our sponsors real fast
you know who it is you love them it's
mints
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything is
that there's always a catch so when i
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium wireless services at just 15
bucks a month i thought
what's the catch but after speaking with
them and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company to sell wireless
services online only by cutting out
retail stores there's no crazy overhead
cost to get passed down to you in the
form of mysterious fees instead
mint just passes on sweet savings
directly to you damn
that's nice to me brother dan is on mint
mobile i am using the mint i and i am
mobile brett
uh it's
they actually send you uh
they actually send you mints when they
uh send you the sim card yes to
lean into the meme a little bit like
that but yeah i've been really happy
with it and it saved me i mean literally
over half of what i was paying on uh one
of the big boys
yeah you know who the the you know evil
[ __ ] yep
yeah so dan loves man it's basically the
same [ __ ] for like it's called literally
the same [ __ ] and it's way cheaper great
um for people looking to save an extra
some extra money mint mobile offers a
premium wireless for just 15 a month the
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text high-speed data and delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network so you
know it is what it is
use your own phone with any mobile plan
and keep your same number along with all
your existing contacts and if you're not
100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their seven day money back
guarantee
switch to mit mobile get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month and to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped right to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
h3tv
that's mintmobile.com
h3 tv cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at midmobile.com
h3tv love you thank you guys i'm liking
that
love our sponsors
[Music]
uh you know what up next we got liquid
iv you know what it do
liquid iv you got one of those dan give
us a demonstration
look it comes in this packaging
you've got the secret sauce slick little
tube sick slick little tube you put it
in the water
you mix it up
you just you got a spoon this time
oh everybody kept yelling at me last
time dan used the package to stir it
pathetic what flavor you got there today
uh this one is green tea i think oh it's
just a green oh no uh lemon ginger
what's the what's the like theme of it
it is
[Music]
energy multiplier
it's got some freaking caffeine oh yeah
oh
i love the energy one cuz look caffeine
sometimes it hurts my tummy it gives me
indigestion it's just cut caffeine ain't
for everybody all the time
army coffee
and there's all these different kind of
flavor formulas you can get from liquid
iv one of them is energy boost with oh
[ __ ] dan is going hard boy let's go wow
and that's proof
that's proof right there that one's
actually
i really like that flavor it's great
yeah lemon ginger flavor
it sounds good yeah but they've got one
for immune strength they've got one for
energy boost they've got one for like um
dehydrate hydro super hydrating
um
and you know during this hot summer we
got to be protective we got to keep our
our body fueled and hydrated
and uh
apparently
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone
they got great flavors like watermelon
strawberry and lemon lime guys
each pack contains five essential
vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana
healthier than sugary sports drink no
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than what's
in an apple and it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and definitely definitely
no soy
thank god because i'm not a beta
what makes liquid iv so effective it's
cellular transport technology the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium
potassium delivers water and nutrients
straight into the bloodstream it's the
perfect balance to help you hydrate more
quickly and effectively than
water alone
also they're donating 4 million servings
in response to covet 19. products are
being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans active
military they've donated over 11 million
servings globally we love them for that
so grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
code h3 at checkout that's 25 percent
off anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using the promo code h3 at liquidity.com
thank you thank you peace love peace and
love
can i just say i love this like stock
music thing yeah this is nice
i love that music too i get so hyped
when you play that one
reminds me of sonic yeah it's a sonic
level yeah for sure
for sure yeah oh one thing i wanted to
get more on so fast one thing i want to
do is be more proactive about saying
subscribe to our channel you guys
slam that bell hit the like button if
you want to see more subscribe
and there's a chance that i will
mr beast is so good he goes if you want
to win a jillion dollars then you need
to be subscribed to my channel i don't
have any offer like that
maybe you'll hire them i subscribed and
now look at me okay so here's the thing
so that
if you okay so if you want
if i do an interview and i find out
they're not subscribed then
they're out there they're out
smash that like button so please
subscribe though just because you know
makes me feel good thank you thank you
um were we talking well we were about to
take this call okay yeah all right i'm
intrigued are we ready to um bring them
on oh jake 20
from maine should we uh look into this
story
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm not a
hundred percent let's let's get it uh
we made a video about the demelio family
not pain
can we find that video is there some
kind of article it might be easier just
to get the you find the video jake made
that would be good to watch before
there's another great one so this girl
kristen is on the line she has a big
beef with lily her cousin she's willing
to bring lily on
their family knows steve miller
from the band
[Music]
but lily is pretending not to remember
and she wants to understand why
wait who's steve miller like you know
well there's stephen miller the the paul
or not politician yeah but there's the
white
psycho yeah yeah but she but is that who
steve miller when i see steve miller i
think steve miller man i think the joker
so lily's like we know him the space
cowboy right yeah
so so some people kristen is saying we
know him
but lily her cousin is saying we don't
know him and she wants to know why
why won't why would you not admit to
knowing him it's such an odd photo the
the framing of that is very strange
what do you want
is she flying like an eagle like what
you know
nice
oh we got we even got uh pro or what is
this
oh proof that this guy is for real sam
the the demilio guy
well let's just talk to jake let's get
the scoop from him
uh
now i'll just say i'm gonna bring jake
on this is the guy who did uh
photography for the demilio family
jake hi how are you thanks for calling
by the way hi how's it going so i just
want to say jake that obviously not
being super familiar with the story
we only have your side to go on so i'm
going to listen obviously to what you're
saying but i think it's important to
note for the audience that
i don't know anything about this story
and uh you know to take everything uh
just remember i i don't know what i
don't know what i'm saying but i just
wanna i'm just trying to cover my ass
bro i'll just be honest with you
sure absolutely so jake i also
yeah i wanna i wanna preface this by
saying i am subscribed and if i if i was
paid from the demilios i would be a
member
oh he's saying he is subscribed to our
channel
thank you bro you're hired you're hired
[Laughter]
i appreciate that
so
do you want me to start from the top
okay so yeah why don't you start from
the top what what tell me like what work
were you doing for them
and how much work you get yeah go ahead
yeah so i uh i was
i took a bunch of photos for them in
december of 2019.
um
i
i did a photo shoot with her when she
had like one to two million followers on
tick tock and now she's at whatever it
is 100 something million
and um
i
i took these photos we had agreed to she
was able to use the photos for
her
an instagram post
um
and i also in the email
said that if
under the the agreement i said if you
decide to sell these photos anywhere i
would like to be notified so that i can
get my my cut or or some sort of
compensation because it was just for a
shout out
and then oh bro
hold on you did a photo shoot for them
for a shout out how big were they at the
time you said
a million okay so they were pretty big
already i mean but you know a million
followers on tick tock right i mean
that's what i'm assuming you mean you're
not like rolling that didn't trans yeah
oh no absolutely not yeah okay
interesting so how long ago was this
uh that happened in 2019 december of
2019 okay and then
uh i
then i started working for them
doing freelance work for
the family in april
um
and then they stopped
then we i stopped working for them just
because they wanted to do everything out
of los angeles and didn't want any
remote workers
um which i thought was fair and then
december of 2020 december 1st the book
comes out and i wasn't notified that my
photos would be used
i wasn't notified uh i wasn't told i
would be compensated um
or anything like that i tried to reach
out multiple times and there was nothing
okay um so what's the name of the book
that came out
uh
essentially charlie of course okay so
essentially charlie so that you're
saying the cover
image they used was your photo
no there are two there are two photos on
the inside and then the photo that one
of the photos that she used for promo
on her instagram had my photo in it okay
so so there's two photos inside the book
that are yours
is there a lot of photos in the book
uh there are
there are 173
so i have
1.57 or something of the photos but okay
and then if they're if i go to
absolutely i'm just trying to understand
the scope of this charlie
emilio and then
and then you said she posted on
instagram one of your photos recently
uh it was it was december 1st it's her
holding up uh is her holding up her book
and then she
in the next slide over my photo is of
her
uh doing a jump in the air
got it
so if it's on instagram is that
violating your contract even though it
was posted like whatever a year
later or something i'm not
i'm not clear on that because it is it's
in a book that's being sold to the
masses i don't know about that but i do
know that it's against the agreement if
it's
if it's in the book and be right
i don't know about the instagram promo
so let's focus on the book so you have
two images
in the book
and did they credit you in the book
uh yes they they they credited me in the
back of the book yes okay
and so the contract clearly states i'm
i'm assuming you didn't have a lawyer
involved in the creation of this
contract i mean you guys all seemed like
kind of small-time contractors
yeah i was 18 when i when i signed it so
and so i had i had no lawyer yeah yeah
and that's understandable here is this
the post here i'm trying to i'm just
yeah that's it okay so
let's see
here's the book
okay interesting so
here's the page with your photo which
one is it the one of her jumping kind of
uh
i'm trying to watch the the stream but
yeah there's only one of her jumping
yeah okay so that's that one and another
one
yes another one in the book that was not
used in the instagram post
on a page that says tips for posting to
social media
tip one don't pay your photographer
okay so this this is interesting so
basically what happened is you realize
hey they put the photos in the book
you reached out to them via the same
kind of channels you had before and
nobody got back to you
i reached out to them through multiple
channels i texted my contact another
contact and then emailed them directly
and everybody ghosted you
you're correct interesting
and
um is how i'm a major publisher because
like publishers are usually pretty
yeah they're directly about clearing
everything
like dan i wonder if it's let me see if
we can anybody it says
abraham's i don't know who it could be
just a self-publishing thing because
it's all just going
yeah can you find the publisher on yeah
because if it's like a real
publisher
i think the publisher would take the uh
liabilities on right which is why
they're usually pretty good about like
anything that they're
publishing they they would make sure
that they have clearance you should try
to find on on amazon who's the public
yeah i just found their website i'm i'm
looking around right now but the pro so
yeah i mean obviously they [ __ ] up
they should have cleared it with you for
sure
i mean absolutely
but like and the the only reason this
took off was because my buddy uh in
front of the show danny gonzalez tweeted
about it oh
right i remember so i remember seeing
this but never really digging into it so
did you make a video about the situation
i did because what's the name of the
video i'm gonna pull it up
uh
i think it's charlie demilio
charlie demilio's team didn't pay me for
my work
okay let's pull this up let's see make
sure it's in the discord i got it here
you are
so
um
interesting yeah this this is
interesting i i wonder what's going how
was it working with them before
you
stopped were they
were they good did they pay you on time
um yes i got so
i'm trying to figure out um
because now that i have been
threatened by them with legal action i'm
trying to figure out
what i can what i'm allowed to say um
but yeah they were they were great
they they were great to work with
um
charlie and heidi are fine but it's the
the team itself are the people who sort
of [ __ ] me over
yeah i wonder if they're even aware so
much of the situation but
they they they are so let me so get to
the point about where they're
threatening to sue you because that
that's a whole
like that that to me
is when this goes way too far instead of
paying like how much money are you
looking for from them would you think
was a fair cut
honestly i
i don't know honestly the only reason
that this is becoming such an issue
right now is like i i would have taken
not like really not that much but tell
me the number didn't reach out
dude i don't know [ __ ] if he's gonna
i don't i i don't know i also i also
don't want to say it out loud because
there are i know that there are people
from the team listening to this right
now
so
i
i'm trying to figure out how this works
so so tell me okay so let's talk here
well like i assumed i think the number
that would have you would have been
happy with wasn't like tens of thousands
right so it's just it's odd to me
correct that they chose to threaten you
legally instead just being like you know
what like here like those people are
[ __ ] a little jacked at this point
with like they're loaded
so tell me about when you found out
about the lawsuit because this to me is
when this story went from oh maybe it's
a misunderstanding to wow these people
are this is [ __ ] up
sure so i i had tweeted about it because
uh my other i i used to take photos for
for uh curtis connor drew gooden and
danny gonzalez on their tour okay um
and
all of them uh started like i tweeted
about it and i was like well
i because i've run into a wall and
nobody's answering i'll just tweet about
it which was
immature on my end i i can admit that i
should have
tweeted about it where's the tweet
let me let me assess the immaturity
level this is this is
because i'm the king of immature tweets
i understand that this is where it gets
interesting um i took all those tweets
down because her manager called me
threatening legal action if i didn't
what the [ __ ] it's like you can't get
him on the phone and then the minute you
talk about it he starts oh you deleted
it
i deleted all of the tweets i do i do
have screenshots of all of the tweets do
you have any screenshots
ava's got abby's got it hey twitter
so they scared you huh what'd the
manager say to you
um well i can say all this um manager uh
called me i picked up it was a los
angeles number so i felt like i knew
what was happening because i don't get
calls from los angeles and he was like
uh hi this is so-and-so with the
demilios i think you know what i'm
calling about and you're like great
you're great i've been trying to contact
you all
month
yeah i would love like i mean 500 bucks
that would be sick buddy but no it's uh
it's it no it's not in the slightest but
he
he called me and was like uh listen i
i understand that you're frustrated
but i need you to now delete all those
tweets or else we'll have to get um
we'll have to get lawyers involved
because you're making false claims and
that's what bothered me is i
i'm not making false claims i have
screenshots of of emails and uh
correspondence with the managers and
it's like
like none of that is
um
i don't know yeah well first of all the
state the statement
is on face not
defamatory like even if you said
even if you have an agreement that says
oh they don't have to pay you if they
reuse it you're making money off of my
photos that is bond itself not
defamatory it's literally just a
statement of your opinion
so this manager is a piece of [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] typical hollywood piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that i despise more than
anyone
bullying and lying that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
that person
[ __ ] them who are they say their name
i'm just kidding you don't have to say
that buddy
i was just i that was a joke that was a
joke
okay you can look it up uh he's very
very well known
um and there's lots of rumors about
misconduct but that's okay wait wait
wait wait i just want to make sure i
don't know who he is dan whisper the
name to me
you could say the name
dan could say the name
say the name i don't want to stir up a i
can't say a man's name you could it's a
woman oh no none of this is associated
with me dan is saying the name yeah it's
not associated with you dan is saying
the name barbara jones i don't know her
okay so i'm glad we did that but i'll
learn about her well also nope
wrong one oh okay so that's not it
doesn't even matter
so never mind not barbara jones all
right well regardless of who the manager
was so they said so go ahead you're
telling how they we're demanding you
remove your tweet
yeah and and
to be honest i
i don't have money and so when he says
when he says
we're we're threatening like we're going
to bring in lawyers i i just listen to
it and i understand that that makes me
look
uh guilty and that makes me no it
doesn't work but they do that because
they know it works because they know
that you don't have money in leverage
and that they're super huge and they
have managers and they're scary they
[ __ ] do that because they know it
works it doesn't make you look guilty at
all it makes them look like scumbags
you do not look guilty you do what
people normally do in that situation
so so after these tweets i i i got that
call and then basically that night i was
on drama alert and i was getting all
this hate
um
saying that i was faking it and all this
stuff and then i decided to make the
video with screenshots and proof to try
to make some sort of wait try to make
this hold on hold on i'm sorry what did
keemstar say about you
uh oh
uh he
he said that i was um
he was just like does he deserve to get
paid i don't
look at nathan just saw red time stamp
it once i've learned keemstar was
involved now i'm on blue oh no
oh yeah i don't know why but have you
guys noticed that keemstar runs like
defense for the demilio family a lot
it's weird
did you notice that
i i noticed that i didn't
yeah maybe he's interested in dixie
sure maybe i don't know but i
i also like i released this video
because i got all these tweets saying
that that i was a grown adult um
harassing a a
a child and i'm 20 years old and she's
17 and i i just wanted to make it clear
that like this is a team against
one-year-old
these girls don't give a [ __ ] it's not
their fault they're not the adults in
the room it's their fam it's their
parents and it's their family i mean the
fact they are mishandling this situation
when they could have just given you 500
bucks and thanked you for your work and
now they're dealing with the [ __ ] pr
nightmare and you're getting [ __ ]
um this is a this is so unnecessary this
whole situation is just so [ __ ] i feel
very foolish yeah
so keemstar made everything so let me
get this straight keemstar made
everything way worse
by
i think it was i think it was pretty bad
i think it was bad originally but he
definitely put some some fuel in the
fire
so have they they haven't formalized any
legal uh
uh posturing other than just they're on
the phone and they said you erase the
tweets or we might uh press charges
uh no sir but then i then i released the
tweets
everything was fine or i deleted the
tweet so sorry i deleted the tweets
everything was fine and then press
started to pick up on it dramaalert
whatever the [ __ ] and then i get 11
texts from that same guy and three calls
saying that i need to say that they were
all false claims right and if i don't
um then there's going to be an issue and
although by the way if you're interested
all those screenshots are in um
are in
the the video
and i can find a time stamp because i'm
also looking at drama
so here here okay so here's his name is
wait why the [ __ ] does it say
his email says charlie
they manage her
they manage her emails and they send it
from her name that seems like horrible
like like
you don't want anyone to think that
charlie demilio is sending you
threatening emails
that's so weird bro
correct
854 is the text
oh 854 okay let's let's skip ahead 8 54.
yeah you know it what just what strikes
me is that this could have been resolved
so easily and so amicably and now it's
turned into this situation because of
poor management like whoever's managing
them is just this is just horrible
not sure if you've seen the press has
started so i'm going to read the text he
sent you
not sure if you've seen but the press
has started to pick up the story and
accuse charlie of things that aren't
true like using photos without rights
it's not accusing charlie i think anyone
with the brain understands you're not
accusing charlie of doing anything it's
her [ __ ] team and family
sure okay and then he licks to dexter
dex serto which i know that dexter toe i
don't know but they post like a hundred
billion articles a day about any brand
of dog food
geo news i've never heard of them
international the news never heard of
them
yeah reliable reputable source yeah it
causes a lot of issues when there is
false info out there charlie and i would
be great dude oh it's so [ __ ] up how
they say like that charlie and i
charlie is so concerned about this
was one of those things geot dot tv is
that what i'm saying
it's uh
geo.tv yeah
i i've never heard of geo.tv here's
their homepage looks very uh bro for all
i know they posted it
geo dot tv
this is like news from also buy
something can i
can i just say something
dude
their whole oh wait grow up i see the
artists
no you're good the two articles at the
bottom of the text are copy and pasted
they're the exact same article
interesting
so i i i have no clue and i know that
literally probably 10 people saw that
definitely 10 people it's not really
press no it's not press
no it's not at all right
but i think they are afraid of the story
getting out and again even now that like
it's out so to speak it's really just
not that like if they would just still
just re just do the right thing just
reach out pay you and that's it nobody's
upset i don't
it only goes sideways when you start
when you get emails like this those are
just psychotic
i am going to continue to read it
right
go for it
charlie and i would be grateful if you
could make a tweet or something stating
that there was a misunderstanding and
she did have the rights to use the
images
that you and charlie are good and asking
everyone to put this behind them bro how
about just giving the guy 500 bucks
like i'm sure her hourly rate or
whatever she earns is way
more than whatever you're asking for
and before you post anything send to me
so we can be on the same page
wow and make sure it serves the purpose
to clear the air and not add more drama
actually change the plans calm down and
then get ready yeah get ready for that
he called me and then he changed his
mind
so what did he say on the call
nothing i i
i didn't answer because i knew that this
guy was he was just spam calling me and
if i answered he was just going to yell
at me and say nothing that would mean
anything to this and so i just let him i
was i was hoping for a voicemail but i
didn't get that i just got three missed
calls and then
these texts so at the end he says just
want to confirm we are not looking for
any tweets or statements hope you have a
good day and again thanks for taking the
time taking the tweets down what a weird
freaking twitter world
this is so bad so stupid it's just such
an easily resolved issue that didn't
need to like
go this way yeah and like you said this
just makes them look way worse in the
long run than just
just being like oh our bad you're the
right thing yeah here's here's a small
sum of money to compensate you see you
so
where where does it stand now when's the
last time you heard from the team
as of now i'm still
uh waiting which i was told
and and i
i don't know
your experience on this but i was told
that if uh
if if they're staying silent then that's
usually not a good thing and they're
making a case um
but who knows um
i i am
i am a little stressed though
well okay so yeah i mean generally
that's probably true that silence means
that they're planning something but i
don't know like
i think it's already a pr like uh train
wreck for them so yeah for them to sue
like i don't know that
that just seems like a terrible they sue
you bro i i don't know i i doubt they're
gonna sue you just because i don't see
how what that benefits maybe they're
sending you a cease and desist maybe you
know that's the only thing i can really
think that's more likely
here's drum alerts coverage of it i'm
curious what uh
what the snitch star said about it
here's running defense for the demilios
probably gets a kickback from them
kickback at that 500 dollars there oh
yeah
oh yeah
the tab is muted for some reason i can
see it oh [ __ ] right right click that
tab at the top yeah
i don't know why that there i got it
back in october uh the demilious
actually called keemstar out for
talking [ __ ] about them oh for real yeah
they said like you're in your 40s
talking about a 16 year old
well he's date he do i mean hey he
doesn't talk [ __ ] about him he dates
them as well so
he's he's fully involved in young girls
his whole life is just fully involved i
still have no illegal though but i still
have no audio what the [ __ ]
uh
yeah right click on the tab bro i'm
[ __ ] okay
do a little set laughing i didn't
remember that it's contributing
for instagram oh okay get out for off my
photos he made million i can't think
about anything bro
okay here we go okay for our first story
charlie demilio over a hundred million
followers
she's scamming charlie tweeted out i
can't think about anything
right
responded by saying i can't think about
anything but the millions you made off
my photos he made millions he's trying
so hard to like
make it interesting or entertaining
it doesn't require this level of energy
no no no
that's the only way to retain such a
young audience you have to keep
screaming
[ __ ]
it's off his photos what fake doodle
tweeted out for proof context showing
that he used to take pictures of charlie
demilio for her instagram oh okay and it
was used in a book huh they do little
sublime look huh
what the [ __ ] what's a book yeah i know
what is a book what is this is that word
wait what is it watch this watch this
showing that he used to take pictures of
charlie demilio for her instagram oh
okay and it was used in a book huh take
two
what the [ __ ] was that
it was used in a book huh
prove it what the [ __ ] was that keemstar
you freaking weirdo
oh okay and it was used in a book huh
said laughing out loud i feel like
people are misconstruing what i'm saying
nobody asked to use my photos i was
never told the photos would be in a book
a credit and a book nothing when they
don't have your permission of course you
got charlie posting a picture with her
book with jack saying me when i never
got paid for my photos now
i guess this is a question to the
audience all right
does jack do little deserve millions
did you ask for millions you dumb you
didn't even say millions he didn't
i don't know i didn't i i don't want
millions i don't know i deserve millions
i said that well that's how he took your
tweet and just completely misread it
well yeah that's how he frames you as
the bad guy it makes you you're asking
for millions big l on my part yeah
you're grabbing a camera and going click
i would i would why is he going to
demean the whole profession of
photography
so much more than that
like no like bro why are you trying so
desperately to defend them it's just a
chemical quack
say no i would say no i feel like people
are buying this book because they're
fans of charlie demilio and they want to
read charlie bro do you not know how ip
or licensing work like what a [ __ ]
tool this guy is
right careful
keemstar keemstar do we can we is there
like a can we cut to something of
keemstar writing an email to karen we
need we need to uh karen here play some
music play some sad music
dear karen
can i i need like a keyboard to make do
you have keyboard sounds
yeah yeah zach go ahead with the
keyboard sounds thank you
dear karen
what's your name
susan yeah sorry come on she's your best
friend yeah
susan
today ethan klein called me a tool on
the h3 podcast
and that hurt my feelings
so badly
maybe it's the midlife crisis i'm
clearly having but
the things he says just hurt
[Music]
i think you should take the video down
and ban him from youtube
i had a really fun day today with my 20
year old girlfriend
we went to the fair
we went go-karting
we played minecraft together
i just wanted to share
anyway susan
your favorite creator
keemstar
p.s
remember when i told ethan on to i can't
even say it don't
cut them off i'm quenching
yeah
all right send that to susan please
signed
your your dreamy kimi
your dreamy kimmy keemstar
[Applause]
i don't think they're sitting there
saying uh you know what i'm buying this
book right now on amazon.com because uh
you know jack doolittle's photos are in
it dude
that's not how ip works they used his
property not my name
oh
wait what did he call you oh how was he
getting this so wrong he oh he called
you jack
he creates it for a living how does he
not understand i how does he
misunderstand ip his argument is that if
they're not buying the book specifically
for your photos they can do whatever
they want with it that's odd that he
right he has literally no understanding
of uh ip
that's not happening should he get paid
for his work yeah possibly but millions
but he didn't ask he set up an argument
he's that's a literal straw man he goes
he's asking for millions should he get
paid maybe but not millions
nobody said millions except you bro
wow how is he real
no i'm not doing it zach nice try
dear susan oh
dear susan hey
today ethan made a video about me
dear susan
and he said
that i made a straw man argument
i'm gonna have to look up what that
means but i'm pretty sure
[Music]
my girlfriend says hi by the way
[Music]
we should reverse the godfather voice
start doing it to him oh
just to get him just to get him to move
on
dude
listen
no okay stop the madness all right
millions and millions and millions of
people know this all right so that's it
wow nice nice transition
speaking of the millions that nobody
asked for
yeah so
yeah i can see i don't understand
why this whole situation
is even happening i'm sorry
here's what i want to do for you though
jake
sure i think the demilio family could
pay you like 500 bucks right and then
you'll be happy i mean i'm now it's all
different thing now it's all legal [ __ ]
i don't know but stay on the line i'm
going to send you 500 because the
demelia family didn't
stop it
emilia family didn't pay you 500. i'm
gonna pay because they're cheap [ __ ]
freaks it's like a romeo or they're
julia where their team is well yeah yeah
so you stay in the lineup okay thank you
very much i'm gonna make you whole go
ahead i have a question go ahead if uh
if uh if you look over my resume can you
keep your five hundred dollars
stay on the line are you in la he did
say he was subscribed i'm not in
i'm going to give you the 500 to make
you whole
and remember demilio family ethan pays
on time that's right and also send your
resume stay on the hold we'll get both
okay
all right thank you so much thank you
thanks for sharing your story um it was
really interesting and you're a great
caller so thank you jake
thank you have a good one all right bye
you too
i just dropped oh [ __ ] i dropped it
did you hit drop i did
sam's taking care of it she has his
number we have the numbers saved it's
all good yeah not bad but we'll take
care of him
yo i don't that's what i don't get it's
like oh my god you guys are mismanaging
this is such a train wreck situation and
this poor guy
is doing all he wanted was a little was
like you know a little compensation for
his work as agreed upon as agreed upon
it really doesn't seem that but even
like technically even if it was like
here's your photos
they should have cleared it with them
even in the even in like
the the case of like here's your photos
it's all good transactions over and they
should have still cleared it with it
yeah
by the way during the call i saw a
commenter that was saying they work in
the publishing industry and um
that unfortunately this is actually
pretty common so i guess interesting i
was wrong about them being pretty
diligent i mean i i
in the world of like broadcasts like
with television and everything they're
super serious about clearing like the
smallest thing so i kind of was just
assuming a big publisher would be the
same way but evidently uh no this isn't
my first rodeo that's what i assume too
because i've dealt with publishing
lawyers and they're so [ __ ] annoying
and like way so over the top
but i guess with right yeah i don't know
i think they
they i don't know why but they just
stomp on these little creators rights
like this guy
just give him 500 bucks guys i did it
you see how easy it is and y'all are way
richer than me guarantee that and the
big difference is how you pay it back
exactly
tom selleck no even tom selleck knows
wow
so listen guys i gotta go pee
when we come back
we have some other great calls lined up
actually
um bruh
this for real olivia mama schizophrenic
and thinks she's in a relationship with
post malone
that sounds like it's gonna be sad yeah
um but this one with lily sounds kind of
or kristen sounds interesting with her
cousin
is we know steven miller but she
pretending she doesn't know stephen
miller okay and i did clarify or
somebody who screened the call clarified
we're talking about steve miller the
musician not not the white nationalist
okay
steve miller from the steve miller band
that's correct
okay this is really interesting let's
talk to lily when we get back
and we have some videos we want to watch
too
got a bunch we haven't gotten to looks
like another five-hour episode boys all
right i'm gonna go to the bathroom i'll
be right back you don't have to go to
the cuts can you guys just talk or to
call out some donations or something
okay yeah sure i'm just gonna pee real
fast
okay let me uh take a look at these here
donations
um
somebody offering to be ethan's
assistant for free
if you get me out of australia
you don't want to come here i mean i
don't know what what your situation in
australia is but
you don't want to come to the states um
has jake tried to contact other
photographers included in the book to
see if they get paid that's a good
suggestion
but he's gone now so uh i guess i should
have read that earlier
what else we got here dude
[Music]
youtube
needs to fix
their [ __ ] chat interface like why
can i not agree at more than like two
donations it's insane you're slipping
youtube it's flip
insane yeah
keemstar
susan let her know uh
to you ela and the crew much love from
israel um was yesterday rosh hashanah uh
eve of russia yes
so yes wait what was that does that mean
today's rosh hashanah yeah rosh hashanah
i believe is
it's the whole week i think i'm a bad
jew dude
did you know that yesterday was the
dinner
well happy holidays guys happy new year
uh for the jewish happy new years fans
out there
he's in love peace and love
uh there were so many more donations and
it literally the the super chats they
just disappear
why does that happen
can somebody explain to that to me in
the chat itself flipped how was your
weekend dan
um it was good i uh i played a lot of
hard to iron for oh nice yeah i did a
full world conquest as the united
kingdom
um so that was pretty cool yeah nice and
um
what else did i do
what did you do
you went to abercrombie and finch yeah i
went through everything it's adventure
i yeah i say amber crombie
just found out lena told me it's at
berkeley so i've been saying wrong i've
seen it [ __ ] people make fun of me first
thing [ __ ] you zach how about that
i say i've seen it but i think better i
saw it excuse my somebody donated oh my
god there's so many donations now i
thank you for solving this issue for me
everybody
uh hannah are you still mad at me i'm
sorry lol that
doesn't seem like it was directed
towards us at all she's not mad anymore
okay yeah no she forgave you don't worry
about it
uh i worked for a publisher in the uk
and they were anally retentive about
clearing everything yeah see that was my
assumption too i don't know there was
another commentary that said that they
they get busted for that all the time
uh hi chat heart
thanks steven
um ethan should hire me as an assistant
i could be the first short king on the
team uh you know what somebody else
donated and asked how tall
is love and that's a good question bad
news for whoever said that first thing
because i'm five seven
oh we do have a short kid
you have a short king i guess so
well it's always been considered as
short
so i think so but swedes are actually
tall right like they're like even taller
than americans yeah so i'm really
shocked
average height of a swedish man is 5 11
really yeah they're tall [ __ ]
oh wow well here in the states you would
be pretty much right at average so
another reason to get you out here
yeah
thank you guys for all the support you
know these shows have been great
the donation the last time we were about
the million views that's that just makes
me so happy and it was down for three
days you know
[Music]
yeah people seem to
dig the h3 tv thank you for all the
donors too you got some good donors
there yeah i've been reading them off i
was complaining youtube
please stand up
someone said no stand up oh please stand
up
he's standing inside h3 crew the whole
crew the whole crew everybody stand up
well love you know on the height
analysis they said you were sick sick so
how'd that feel
yeah
i guess i radiate some 66 energy some
big radiate tall guy energy yeah some
guys just stand tall you know and they
stand tall big feeker vibes
yeah
so let's let's move on
i'm captivated by this kristin
this kristen
let's talk to her
um this could go sideways though but
let's let's trade carefully and see hey
okay kristen
okay
hey can you hear me yes i can hear you
fine thank you for calling okay so so
the situation sounds a little unusual a
little bizarre
yeah
yeah so
you guys know
steve miller the musician
with physical evidence what's the
physical evidence
okay so
it's it's not me who knows steve miller
it's like my extended family and
so i'm kristen my cousin's name is lily
and my brother and i of her you know
cousins
we have the same
memory of their family being friends
with steve miller from the st miller
band and she like claims to not know
about it i'm like how would i know
that you guys like saw him in austin
texas and like went to the show and they
have this this photo in their house
that's uh you know how sometimes people
would write like an uh signature on the
right like to
ethan like from steve miller they have
this photo in their house that's of the
three of the siblings and steve miller
has written like two lilly like two
like my other cousin's name so lily is
lily in the photo
yeah yeah she's like three years old for
some reason
so their friendship my it's my uncle
sorry to clarify it's my uncle that is
friends with steve miller
lily's dad
yeah yeah yeah yeah my uncle okay
and so lily claims that
her family doesn't know steve miller
yeah she's like i have no idea what
you're talking about can i can i put it
for the theory that i
wouldn't it be wouldn't it stand to
reason that lily
whose dad
is apparently the one that's friends
with steve miller
would know more
than you about her proximity
to steve miller
i mean probably but
this is what we have beef over so that's
why
okay can we get lily on the phone i did
yeah yeah i can message somebody on
discord yeah let's get lily on the phone
because
it seems to me you say lily's pretending
you think that she remembers but she's
lying to you
i'm not sure i mean it was just it was
recently my brother and i were like why
do we have the same memory of this and
she was like
i have no idea what you guys are talking
about and we're like you told us about
this
i don't know but i tried to do some
research i texted my aunt and my uncle
oh really
so wait what did your uncle say and what
did your aunt uncle say
so my aunt was like let me ask your
uncle basically and she's like i don't
remember that but if we did um it would
have been when lily and my uncle went to
see him in austin i'll ask him okay that
was a few minutes ago she was like i'll
ask okay wait
does your uncle say he was friends
with steve miller
i'm not sure because i mean that didn't
mean that
that's the lynchpin here
yeah i
i don't know i've been trying i got i
tried to get in contact with them
this is such an interesting phone call
well it seems to me christian that you
are making assumptions about their
family that probably are not true
i mean lily would know
and certainly you're the thing is that
it seems like if i had to guess maybe i
i would say based on the information i
have that you're wrong
well my brother and i we have the same
memory and we've only talked with her
like as of late
and she said
no i don't know what you guys are
talking about but why do my brother and
i have the same memory well it's like
it's an odd thing how long ago how long
ago was this
uh
like the conversation yes
it was like uh
it was like probably like three weeks
ago at a family thing
no but how long ago was the memory
oh um
i mean it would have been as recent as
like seven or eight years ago when
she went to this concert in austin texas
so yeah it would have been friends and
had like these tickets to go like
literally she would have been around him
okay
i think i think you know have you heard
this phenomenon of false memories
i think you're experiencing a false
memory
it's possible that you and your brother
together
have created
a false memory and that lily
is the one telling the truth all along
that's my theory
okay well bring lily on because i'm team
lilly right now
okay
let's talk to lily cause i i feel like
there's i feel like she's right she's
got to be right and you've got to talk
to
her mom and dad because i mean y'all are
outside the box
all right where's lily yeah the butt my
okay
um i can who should i message on discord
um who should she message on discard
she's got lily a weenie uh we need to
call this other person
um
yeah i said that i have their number
should we okay listen kristen with peace
and love
i'm team lilly on this one dude you got
to get more info you got to talk to the
uncle
hold on hold on i think you're wrong i
typed in my uncle's facebook i typed in
my uncle's facebook and i said to steve
miller
and he made a post and he goes you know
those whatever he's like an old person
so he posted like these are 10 people
that i have met
uh that are truths or whatever and one
person that's a lie
and in the moment
it's like people he's jammed with i
guess
let me read this again so he's like
people
i've met
yeah and it's like 10 musicians and he
goes one's alive
and it's a long list of people
and they're all true except for one but
whatever steve miller is one of the true
ones so he just so he jumps and he's
answering
all right so he's answering people who
are like this is who i suspect is a lie
and uh someone goes steve miller and he
writes no i've met him
traded and sold with him a few times his
wife and him are really cool and we have
jammed that's what he
said doesn't sound like
okay you know what you gotta apologize
to lilly
you're wrong here sorry kristen with
peace and love no i'm not here
thank you thank you kristen take care
apologize to lily's tell her you're
sorry
bye thank you
[Laughter]
really deserves an abolishing apology
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right let's watch some videos
um
yo this shit's crazy oh you want to
watch gabe is mad over labor yeah
i love this man
he never misses
you know when i saw this i was like i
agree i kind of agree i want i i'm right
here
should i eat this ice [ __ ]
god damn it i'm so [ __ ] disappointed
[Music]
i love this high-pitched game [ __ ]
what's he eating a big-ass thing ice
about
will he baby no am i right that he asked
if he should
but why he kind of seamlessly translated
should i eat this big thing
should i eat this ice [ __ ] is he
hungover is that a remedy for hanging
out no nothing i've ever heard of no
remedy for brain for you
sorry
donated 100 said fika fund
just wanted to buy you guys lunch today
hope it's enough
thanks for being the best part of my
week xxx wow
thinking about lunch thank you
thank you thank you very much pika for
life what do you guys want to get
different lives this one's on what was
her name shoshana this one's on
shoshanna
yeah so um you guys should let's order
lunch so for sure sorry guys but if you
want if you want us to do a long episode
we're gonna have to eat in the middle
and yes i've seen the flies okay i've
seen the flies flying around
no i know i saw the comments we were
like there's [ __ ] flies i saw them
we're going to get into more of that
when ela's here
or on off the rails not today yeah i
don't want to talk about the flies
anymore to be honest i regret the fly
discussion nope you brought it up
i i i have i have i did more to add but
we're gonna do it okay yes there's flies
you really hear it man i mean [ __ ] yeah
yeah they're buzzing that mic man you
hear that
amy you got that photo
you want to do this now
i mean it's up to you i don't mind
what photo
show the photo maybe
since we're talking about it uh-oh
go ahead i would have worn my suit today
if i knew i was playing uh
litigator
these guys want to pin this on me
now i'm not saying that fruit doesn't
attract flies like i'm not saying that
people think that i'm saying yeah are we
talking about this again this caused
such a headache all right
fine
just show the photo ap
my point was that yes of course i'm
contributing to the fly problem i'm
stepping it up i'm getting rid of my
stuff and by the way people think that
we live in that dumpster we have
cleaners come twice a week and i say dan
if you need more cleaners do go
the dogs are getting walked now they're
not going to be going to the bathroom
inside they're potty trained but you
know ew what is this
i'm sorry i was muted ethan is innocent
what am i even looking at this was in
the refrigerator uh
this was in the refrigerator that's
disgusting do you think this is now when
you talk about rotted fruit
fruit flies do you think this is a fruit
fly situation dan
i mean obviously that's and
that was in the fridge did you find a
bunch of dead fruit flies as well maybe
i did i sent you another photo
okay
thank you
here is the uh
here is where he found it above dead
fruit flies
now what do you now guys now i'm just
saying here
yeah i mean obviously that's gross okay
thank you and the fruit flies are
generally in that vicinity right yes yes
i say we owe you an apology yeah that
does seem fairly exonerating i don't
know
does anyone want to own this one this
was in the back of the refrigerator
right i go into that refrigerator to
grab a lacroix and that's about it i
don't i don't i don't touch that does
anyone want to own this
i mean strawberries who who why did we
even have strawberries i didn't know we
had strawberries
that's
no clue what the [ __ ]
nobody's gonna own that one i have a
feeling
i mean it's like groceries right like
who owns the groceries
there was also a massive food dump from
teddy fresh
a lot of fruit
oh that's not that's not from teddy
fresh because all the teddy fresh
strawberries had the end cut off
thank you baby
mmm trying to pass the buck once again
well it's office groceries it's not like
dan strawberries or zac strawberries i
mean well clearly nobody
uh okay well regardless thank you so
that other photo of all the flies where
like i couldn't tell like what was that
a photo of that was just the crevices of
the fridge there's a bunch of dead nets
in there let me go to the chat is it my
exonerated or oh god the chat's going so
fast people are saying ian did it yeah
it sounds like ian did it he's making
excuses i'm just reading the chat
it's ian ian ian is guilty yeah
everybody's blaming you dude
yeah i don't know who it is but i know
it's not dan people are saying it's my
strawberries come on you guys what what
seriously
i i i don't uh you know those aren't my
strawberries actually i take it back
lacroix and the potato chips are the
only things that i really ever touch in
the sauce
i'm exonerating myself
there are i'm getting flies today though
i don't know why
we even set up a flag trap we got a fly
trap it seems to be effective there's a
lot of flies a bunch of them how many of
those we should get like five of them
just
all right
just [ __ ] wrap it up baby genocide
all right so gabe is mad
um me too man zach zach put out a spicy
tick tock that's actually going a little
bit viral
really
i haven't seen this a little bit he
showed it to me this morning i hadn't
seen it but like i mean
six thousand likes uh that's that's
viral oh but it has music copyrighted
music doesn't it zack yeah but
it's silence of the lamb music where
goes
oh top comment ethan's gonna have a
great time with this one
[Music]
second comment this does this alone
deserves an
apology
[Music]
oh well i can't listen you're gonna have
to mute it
damn you can get my whole [ __ ]
episode claim for your tick dog zack
what you gotta hear what he says right
here though it's the whole he said would
you [ __ ] me i would [ __ ] me
like from yeah no i get it can i you
seem disturbed dan do you want to come
not let's just start just there's a few
there's a few things here
that are throwing me for a loop first of
all uh it i guess maybe it makes more
sense if you um
hear it with sound but uh hashtag j in
silent bob so all right so
yeah
that sound was from clerks too oh
from jay and silent bob doing it because
i couldn't find the original sound on
tick tock so okay okay that makes a
little bit more sense yeah
um yeah why did you make this
i don't know i was watching silence and
lambs over the weekend no okay that i
mean that's okay and i i i've always
like
trolled my friends my buddy of like
he'll come over and do a little trolling
i'll come i'll come out with like a
like a shawl over me and like do the
mangina when he gets there stop wait
wait hold on this comment is so good
someone tagged me and said i don't know
if you guys have hr so i'm sending this
to you
so zach sent this to me we always send
take toxic opinions here and there or
whatever
i said i love you zach do not post that
well and it seems like you were wrong
because it's i said it's going a little
viral i actually think it's funny thank
you i i actually
no it's funny and and it makes
it makes more sense if you just watch
silence of the lambs that you like the
meme on it i thought it was just out of
the blue which would be very strange no
no no like this is always a scene like
that i've you know
you really relate to i mean this stick
if you want to talk about like don't
post that yeah i mean the one of zach
going ha ha what was it
that video actually got taken down
she like claimed me or she it was i got
a strike or some [ __ ] yeah because you
were making forever for being fat
weren't you no
no oh she she had a small ass ha ha and
you have no ass what would you say
i forget
that was the word that i mean i thought
that was in their drafts or did you
after you watched it
you
dude what the hell
dude are you really showing your feet
off like come on zach let's just
interpret what it's an ad for uh
this is his cameo god
yeah but why you gotta show your feet
like i don't know just laying back dude
i'm chilling
bro come on you know what you're doing
this is your cover or your cover
i got a nice feet it's not it's not a
slide you
oh
hello there
ian i see you i see you in the chat
you'll get me every time we'll get back
to this
someone's trying to sway the chat saying
uh
i planted the strawberries over the
weekend
oh oh oh uh i'm ready to double back i
you know i'm ready to litigate this if
you want i am totally already litigating
go ahead let me pull up the strawberry
photo okay so we are litigating the
strawberries and i'm just happy that the
the heat is off me for a moment i'm just
asking you ahead of time you sure you
want to do this i'll stop it amy he
wants to do it yeah you are you really
going to dunk on him that hard that's
what you make it sound like you don't
want to do this you don't do this man
okay let's do it
well my my main issue is well first of
all
are you insinuating i bought
strawberries no okay who bought the
strawberries i don't know okay so right
away boom
how's this my fault
i just come to think of it i don't
remember anyone buying strawberry also
can anybody in this office attest to
seeing these strawberries ever no
now who was here all weekend
i mean
that's who suddenly shows up on monday
with pictures of flies and strawberries
you know what that's inappropriate abe
was here cleaning the whole baby did a
monstrously good job cleaning and
organizing i got to stand up for a b
thank you to answer your question yes i
was the one here cleaning all weekend
and setting up
so ethan was originally the person
blamed for the flies yes
he sends his
who's to make yourself proclaim simp to
the office okay let me let me add these
photos just show up interesting let me
ask you this ian because you're so
[ __ ] clever now
okay are you accusing abe of bringing
dead fruit flies and planting them in
the fridge
look i don't know the lengths who bought
the groceries who bought the groceries
this guy planted a whole family in a
burger
[Laughter]
who bought the groceries
i guess it would have been it would have
it would have been sam it would have
been sam or olivia yeah who bought this
they go and they go and buy stuff for
the kitchen who bought this who bought
the strawberry motherfucker's going
upstairs now oh they're upstairs i
forgot i don't know if i don't know if
it's the person who
bought its responsibility that's what's
my original point is is the fire i'm not
blaming hold on hold on i have something
else okay go ahead
when we got plants why did i attest to
not getting real plants what did i say
they would not be taken care of they
would not be watered who got these
plants and why are they all dead who
bought the plants
what's good that's not my problem i
didn't who bought the plants
was so know who bought the plants i
i honestly don't eat it was it you i
didn't buy plants who bought the plants
baby someone bought the plants at the
instruction of hold on ian someone here
you know about the plants who bought the
plants baby you know what i'm not
talking about the plants because the
plants should go ahead baby bring in
more flies they're dead they're [ __ ]
sitting there dead all over the office
did you just say i bought the plants
maybe no i didn't but if you want to
take the blame for whoever did do it
feel free
okay i just gotta say what kind of plant
is that baby what kind of plant is that
you tell me a venus [ __ ] flytrap
right so tell me right how is a [ __ ]
guy
gonna be attracted because it's dead it
ain't catching no [ __ ] fly you're
really dead bro the fights are catching
it it's a venus [ __ ] fly trap yeah
it's more like a at this point it's a
venus fly lure a cop can't arrest you if
you're dead dude
that's not true you can wake up dead
you can wake up dead how can you wake up
dead you're already dead how can you
wake up if you're dead you can wake up
dead you literally can't by the
definition you can't wake up dead it's a
morning you wake up dead
okay and you know how i found the
strawberries because i was cleaning out
the fridge thank you
i say you planted them you got those
pictures of the dead plants too uh ab
because you sent the i'm just saying i'm
not blaming anyone i'm just trying to
take the heat off myself a little bit
here because there's rotted food
there's [ __ ] i i brought up the flies
at first yes i was just apologizing to
ethan thank you finally you know what's
interesting as well as ethan you seem to
know of all of these damning photographs
we're in a big group chat none of us
have seen these pictures so that means
that there was a sidebar about yeah
for this moment right here you knocked
on you guys i know how you do when it
comes to cleaning such a tv straight up
i just [ __ ] yes i'm very clean and it
drives me in the same in the office no
button like listen so clean then ian do
you are you saying you don't your
problem the truth because you had no
problem you know
dunking on me talking about
food and fruit and but all of a sudden
when more evidence comes out it's all
about oh abs what's up with you you
don't care about truth ian i mean what
exactly is your point
i'm about truth that's why you brought
this back around
i think it's so what exactly so what
exactly is your problem with ab bringing
more evidence i also would like to say
that the original fly [ __ ] dog poop
conversation i was very much removed
during that conversation so i don't
think i should be taking oh no no it was
no no it was definitely me who brought
it up me and dan and i was apologizing
to ethan that's why i sent it to him
thank you
you know but i do have something left
closed i have one more thing i would
like to litigate this is separate this
is a very separate issue here by the way
before you go people were saying dead
plants leave flies oh really is that why
these are all over the [ __ ] office
go ahead
i don't know this is [ __ ] great dude
there's some [ __ ] chatter between you
guys man
this is real [ __ ]
this is real [ __ ] what's rigged zack
what's red
this is real [ __ ] it's rigged dude oh my
god
go ahead ian make your final point
it's not about this i was ready to move
on i think okay you want to you moving
on to another battle
yeah a different battle okay go ahead
okay this is a separate thing
this is the third episode we have 10
things in the document by the way people
are saying higher cleaner we have a
cleaner that comes twice a week you guys
this is not a [ __ ] you all made it
sound like this is a total dump here
it's clean it's hygienic we have
cleaners twice a week
dan you made it sound like a dump you
want to say anything big massive dumps
me yeah
they call them dumb no i don't i don't
know i don't yeah no it's fine it really
yeah
but they say it does look good around
here because a b we'll give them
it was all fun and games last week but
everybody got so mad about it yeah over
this past week and i can't believe we're
doing this again on the show because
this is a whole new [ __ ] headache
that you all have just created when all
the heat's coming on me
thank you they call them dumps
oh somebody someone donated ten dollars
and said the house plant is 100 the
cause of the gnats
they breed in soil you can buy a
pesticide called bonnet
systemic house plant insect control
together there you go they're breeding
in the soil
the venus fly trap has
uh what a what a
the most ironic death ever being a
supply chain that is true all right ian
you want you want to cause more [ __ ] or
or
do you want to move on i was just
wondering why we have 10 items in our
document you read all nine except one
which was
an update on
my mr verified email oh i just swear i
didn't see it wait
wait wait wait wait wait this is the
third oh
you know what because it wasn't blue i
just skimmed over it that's my bed
i want to you want me to do an email
right now
you don't have to do it on air i'm not
forcing you to do it that was someone
suggested no i i put it i put it you're
right i put it in there yeah it was my
idea
no it's fine it's fine
we're gonna we're gonna do it uh this
week okay
oh okay
yep
um two dollar donation move along okay
for once i agree
i'm trying so y'all keep pulling me back
in
what can i do
all right owen wilson wilson
finally and now ethan
this is the first time for me on the h3
podcast hi i am ethan and i am in the
podcast h3 after dark that's perfect
that's exactly what they do man
yo reddit player what the [ __ ] hi i am
ethan and i am in the podcast h3 after
dark
that's so good
this is the first time for me and reddit
comments
it's awesome
oh
shout out to marvel
good marketing
okay this is great train wrecks we had a
huge debate with this guy train wrecks
on twitch
who does gambling all day long
on twitch and we're like yo
this website is shady
we don't know what's going on the fact
that they are sponsoring you and they
could be fudging the numbers
and you know
uh a whole debate ensued
where xqc and train wreck got on the
stream and were
uh very upset very very upset
with my insinuation that stake of all
websites
would fudge their numbers
especially when we found their
headquarters which was a hut
and a small island in the caribbean
though the hut that we um that we showed
on stream um
did end up being
not the correct hut it actually ended up
being another hut directly next to that
it was a little nicer hut it was a
little bit of an it had a fresh coat of
paint yeah i love that that was like the
comeback is like oh you guys got it
wrong here's the real hut in in a tax
haven uh caribbean island it's like oh
okay yeah that's much better it was a it
was a lightly refurbished hut
so here's train wreck now uh you know a
mere like month later
oh this is so good you guys [ __ ] bro
it's just it's it's just like i don't
know man like i like i've tried like
dude i sense take a message today i'm
like you listen like
i have tried bringing you know
i'm like listen i need to know what's
good you know what i'm saying like are
we just dealing with extreme insane luck
like i need to know what's happening
because this like i have
put my name behind this [ __ ] my brand on
this [ __ ]
because i want to gamble i want to be
clean
and it's like you know what i'm saying
because like this is some [ __ ] where
like if in five years some [ __ ] it's the
fan like that's on me
so it's like it's getting to that point
where i don't even know if i feel
comfortable anymore you know what i'm
saying like
[ __ ] and this is the worst time for me
to say any of this because i'm [ __ ]
down a good amount
everyone's [ __ ] down in my group
everyone buddha's down prods down i'm
down [ __ ] the entire world is [ __ ]
down
all of a sudden this [ __ ] goes
on a losing streak it's just it's it's
they're [ __ ] the numbers
am i crazy is that what i was saying
more or less i mean uh well here's
what's here's what's gonna happen when
these guys decide they've
it's time for them to scramble they
fudge the numbers against them take all
their [ __ ] money back and then they
disappear
yeah
perfect crime sounds pretty
straightforward
yo train wrecks literally sitting in an
empty apartment like what bro
well because he moved to canada so that
he's keeping he was in his website he
was in this apartment when we talked to
him last there's like nothing i don't
think yeah i mean i don't think he does
anything he doesn't gamble the view is
beautiful though
love that view
yeah what the hell man what a life
i know man
i kind of feel bad for him
well he's just he's he's obviously in a
brutal addiction to gambling and yeah i
also i'm afraid that he might be in some
legal jeopardy
if he if this really is turns out to be
a scam and provable and investigated
because he's continuing to pedal it and
he's going to be a star he's going to be
a person of interest they're going to
want to subpoena all of his
conversations with the owner
yeah i mean
if they actually go after steak which
i would not be surprised at all
well i don't know
but i just thought it was funny that uh
that's what i said
[Laughter]
is he gambling right now
if he's if he's live then probably not a
lot of viewers vaccinated
oh [ __ ] all these commercials he's
got 31 000 followers watching gamble
the name of that the name of the stream
is 18 plus do not gamble
ad
i mean look dude when you it's just
become a meme like you really think that
people take that seriously it's a meme
do not gamble lol
18 plus ad gamble lol don't gamble
i mean the [ __ ] bro
is gambling
flashbacks yeah let's watch this
come on
come on baby something come on baby
[Music]
that would have been nice come on hold
on hold on
all right the goodbye spins and little
fight i'm going to leave
and then you have to listen to the
shitty gambling music too come on [ __ ]
some stupid phenomenon where you just
get us in people watch this i guess love
said it's entertaining but i can't for
the life of me
you watch this [ __ ] bro oh yeah is it
just to watch him suffer and lose
i mean
towards all the like negative about him
he's like actually kind of funny sure i
understand he's entertaining
yeah so he's been streaming for a long
time so he's he knows how to entertain
sure i sent you a pretty funny quick by
the way i'll take one 1000x on a 150
dollar bat so can you i saw this clip
can you describe what's actually
happening here
like i saw he won like 2.5 million right
but i didn't understand that one 1000x
so the further out to the size you get
the more you get because the probability
of you coming on the side is actually
kind of low okay so if you go there you
get times one thousand and i don't
what's his bet
oh so you get times a thousand if you go
all the way out okay
and then just never so he said let me go
back i'll take one 1000x on a 150 dollar
back one just one thousand you bet a
thousand i'll do the same thing
2500
i will literally just chill wait and
every ball is a bet please just give me
it like every time you click 2500
[Music]
this is also steak by
i'm sorry but
i don't get it yeah oh yeah hell yeah
yeah let's get some food sam and olivia
what do you guys want to eat someone
bought us uh what was your name again uh
who bought us some lunch shoshanna
we love
i love it
i mean i guess it's a spectacle to see
someone
like bet so much right 1 250 per ball
but is it a spectacle when you realize
the platform's literally paying for his
bets
he's in the hole a lot though i think
like badly you guys want chick-fil-a
[ __ ] frank never did oh dan says no
yeah and also they hate gay people which
isn't cool
it's it's hard like they literally hate
gay people and they
they they put money towards
anti-lgbtq causes
uh
i don't know to be honest so like
it's trick
it is kind of hard it does make it kind
of sour to support them in a way because
they're actually just such like you know
um in and out puts bible verses but as
far as i'm aware they don't actually
like actively
try to disenfranchise uh lgbtq people
[ __ ] fried chicken
[ __ ] fried chicken hey what do they
serve at uh chick-fil-a gabe
who deserves fried chicken meat right
what do they serve there
[ __ ] fried chicken right that's right
oh my god what is this to which streamer
apologizes after admitting she faked a
cancer diagnosis what though
[ __ ]
this one's pretty wild
ugh what twitch streamer miss dirty bird
claimed to have brain and lung cancer
she said she would need a lung
transplant is that possible lung
transplant
if you have lung cancer
or you're just asking if a lung
treatment yeah
that was like
if they can transplant a heart that can
transplant a lung life
i don't know that that's true
i don't know lung transplant after a
brain surgery would take place
yeah lung transplant is a thing
wow just looked it up pretty amazing
they can they can
pretty much do anything but a brain i
think
and and and we're working on that that
would be the most helpful for a lot of
people
get you a new brain
um
miss dirty bird's sister on stream
saying her sister is lying holy [ __ ]
this is a gosar moment
what do you guys want to eat though for
real
i don't care
what i do care because you veto
chick-fil-a
uh because there's literally nothing i
can get from there
so why don't well you got you guys talk
and talk to them and then figure it out
you're
you're buying well shashana's buying is
buying no i'm just saying i don't want
to talk about you guys figure out what
you want suddenly you don't want to talk
about food on the air well if we're not
getting anywhere
mexican yes okay let's do mexican
easy
i left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt
that's how i feel a hard time the rest
of the weekend god i have such a hard
time
anyway here is her sister
um
bro this is crazy her sister saying
she's lying
i just wanted to address
my sister's stream today
um her having cancer
i don't think
she hasn't said anything to any of us
the only surgery that we know of
is her foot
it's almost the one um it hurts me that
she has said this because
as of three days ago it was five years
ago that my
gran passed away from small cell lung
cancer
so
the fact that she is lying about having
cancer hurts me
oh my god i just wanted to address so
what was she lying about just to try to
raise money or something or just get
people to sub
uh here is uh mrs dirty bird admitting
she lied about having i'm assuming she's
not a popular streamer is she
uh not mega popular but um has a
following really
yeah
dude
not only did she make a statement that
she had cancer she would consistently
post updates on the status of her health
in order to garner sympathy
she wrote update day seven officially
one week last night was really rough i
haven't gotten any sleep the doctors
were saying i might need a lung
transplant and a few others too what are
a few other transplants we're
transplanting everything inside
swapping out parts left and right
she has 50k followers on twitch so i
don't know
not nothing not nothing they won't know
until they opened me up to take a look
but they
can't do that right now i'm a little
stronger for my last surgery if i go in
for another surgery right now i have a
higher chance of not surviving it i
spent all day yesterday with the doctors
and they were trying to get me to move
around a bit
i still can't hold my head up by myself
but i'm getting there what the [ __ ]
pretty dramatic
you're gonna love this next part though
apparent okay so so here is her uh
admitting to lying
recording all right
what the [ __ ] jeremy call invite jeremy
all right
what's the context here hello
so she she called in to to make an
apology but the the key thing is here
the apology is word for word from a
scripted monologue from
teen suicide awareness film wait let me
watch cyber bully
no [ __ ] way
wait so let me watch this first so we
know
because
[Music]
okay so this is
her apology
yeah i don't know why people should lie
about having cancer after games but she
makes an apology reading from a script
of cyberbully
so this is what she's reading
it's it's from this movie okay watch so
here's the script let's follow don't
even know me hate me
or maybe i do
because now i hate me too oh my god it's
literally
okay i'm sorry she actually has 2k
followers
okay i know that no one's gonna want to
listen
that's okay
it's right now
i don't see a reason for trying
or for talking
or for breathing
oh my god it's worked for a world i'm
just dead
i don't know why people
that don't even know me oh started over
yeah
oh
dude
interesting oh
painful
it's kind of a
pretty interesting story
like
i wonder if she this is all just part of
her troll campaign though
like she intentionally did that knowing
like she must have known she's trying to
just get negative uh negative
attention okay good i clicked the right
button no just uh
either side so she called in someone
else's stream to apologize yeah right
you probably which you know
i love how these people all have like
serious conversations over like
dude walking through a war zone
oh she put out a new apology
uh everybody's spamming the uh the
cringe overload emo uh emote of you
yeah seriously
that's fascinating to me that like she
oh here's the new one okay so this one
is
um not copyrighted
this is authentic real apology
apparently at least until somebody finds
where it's from this that's that would
be honestly i feel like i would apprec i
would respect that if she found another
apology to plagiarize there was another
um
help me out guys there was somebody
famous who who
made an apology
and they and they uh plagiarized their
entire apology who was that
i recall that as well oh that's right
shia labeouf shia labeouf [ __ ] his move
that's right okay so he he made up the
whole movie he plagiarized the movie
and then he apologized and he stole the
applause so that's kind of a that's kind
of like a high level player you kind of
like doubled down on it in a way
but so let's see
it's my official apology video
no cuts no scripts
nothing
what i did
was
undeniably [ __ ] up
yeah and should never have happened
and
oh [ __ ] i am
sorry
everybody that i've hurt
everybody that i've let down
and
just
everything in general
and
there is no excuse for it
there is no reasoning that shut up
[ __ ] zack
and that about wraps that part up
and that's about all i have to say about
that in the words of uh forrest gump
yeah let's just end on that
and that's all i have to say about that
[Laughter]
oh man
yo should we bust out the the original
that we clipped out i think it's done no
no no no no no no no no no no no no i
think it's time it's not it's not end
end of the end of the year end of the
year why are we waiting for end of the
year it needs more time
zach pulled that on
i'll just say what happened no i think
if really don't show it i think it's
better to just show it rather than
you guys are saying don't even talk
about it whoa
without without
nothing i feel like we're at this point
in our lives where we could show this
it's so funny and it piggybacks off this
anecdote
all the time
i wouldn't talk about it i would
i think it's great i think now it's the
time maybe
who even has it i have it i was watching
it last
night i was looking for another video
and i found it yeah and i put in my
favorites bro
all right [ __ ] it all right let's do it
[ __ ] it let's do it
it's not we just guys it was a joke it
was funny we decided that it was it went
a little too far and we caught it but
and people are going to understand that
it was all in good humor we're only just
telling this because that sound bite is
so notorious everyone was basically on
the floor
that was the funniest moment
if we're doing this
no it's just a joke and and we took it
down but now we're at the point where we
want to reflect
i think we should do it i think it's
hilarious all right [ __ ] it you have my
vote so let's just roll it you know what
just roll give it to dan or ian and
let's just roll it
let me see what chad thinks
they're gonna say show it i mean it was
the funniest like moment ever
it's not that bad he just trisha was
talking
no
[Laughter]
and zach hit the sound bite
and now i even show it there we go yeah
that's it
let's just play it it's not that bad you
guys
send the clip a b it's processing it
it's uploaded to drive everyone deserves
to everyone deserves here comes the hate
mob
cancellation speed runs so whatever
happens after this it's not a
cancellation i want you guys to know i
love all of you in this room
look at it and we'll ride through it
together we we're like yo why did you
we're like come on like that was
inappropriate but zach was just trying
to be funny which we love him for that
and it was funny and but it was
inappropriate it was the placement the
placement was so random
it's not that bad all right
give it to ian and just roll it without
comment without pausing just roll it you
guys uh put it
like putting it into the yeah
i think it's easier to just open it and
put it on oh i think it's still
processing but i sent the link okay
it says i don't have access we're really
doing this huh we're doing we're going
for it huh
yep we are
we've explained
well love have you seen it
yeah
i might i think i was there love ian and
myself are are
all saying this is not a great idea
but
it's it's your clip to show see i don't
understand why i mean it's funny it's
just it was a little bit i can't deny
that it wasn't funny it was it's very
funny it's very funny it's not like he's
just he just played a sound butt
of you know the rock saying shut up
[ __ ]
you're taking away the impact
i'm going to go through hell for nothing
let's just watch it let's let's just
watch it i sent it is it okay let's just
watch it it's processing around giving a
second
let's just [ __ ] watch it you know
i don't think listen
because i'm the one that played it so if
anything i'm gonna get the one with the
most [ __ ] heat up right it was so
good that i even offered to say that i
did it to cover for zach
it's 100 me zach's like if i'm going to
go zach we don't have to play it i don't
want to make you uncomfortable no play
it i don't think you can i knew this was
going to happen and we had a great shut
up [ __ ] moment and it kind of just
leads perfectly into this point that we
can you know talk about uh we can talk
about it
i don't know why it's taking so long to
process here it'll let me download it
now let me just do that
i'm trying to figure out what to get
from this just started working for me oh
wait i heard it i heard it i heard it
all right all right go ahead
there we go full screen it it's full
screen gg
really good making people wait
wait it's not that it doesn't seem long
enough like we reflected on it for a
while didn't we
okay let's go almost two minutes long
okay go ahead
and it felt really good and i think
people obviously people liked that so
much more i saw a tech talk of this
amazing artist named inky which i
actually met her
jesus zack what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh that was so inappropriate
zach that was so [ __ ] up
zach what the [ __ ]
that was not i'm laughing because of how
i'm not laughing
that was so inappropriate
the timing of that was just not okay
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you dude
i'm sorry trisha i'm laughing but not
i'm laughing at how obscene that timing
was and not
that's not appropriate
to [ __ ] dude
why there
of all places would you do that
that was so
wrong
that was not that was not cool
well i was just going to ask do you
accept her apologies hack
do you guys accept her apologies she's
apologized to you guys
see what i mean look it wasn't that bad
right
oh man
it feels good to finally have it out
there i know i feel better
i don't think it was that bad
you know
it's definitely the hardest i've made
any of you laugh
yeah i mean at the time things were more
sensitive i think you know so
it made sense to cut it but now it'll
there's this amount of tomatoes being
thrown in the chat why why are we
getting tomatoes i assume because they
thought it was
not cool oh
i mean
most people are are
live should we take a poll
i mean listen it was just uh let's take
a poll i didn't see a lot of tomatoes
someone said 50 videos coming
oh yeah
i
exactly tried to joke and you know
sometimes but it was funny it did work
but like to collect you know we don't
like to use that word right right right
you just got to go for it but it wasn't
you it was the rock no no it was the
rock it was dwayne johnson i don't see
okay i see one person doing tomatoes i
see hearts i see beaches
it was it was it was up a little bit but
yeah
not a ton of people but i looked over
and there were lots
on the screen is that something that's
colloquial where people throw tomatoes
at us when we're not funny uh
yeah you know
y'all throwing tomatoes at us it started
uh
i think it started in the pre-show stuff
when we would be late to start streaming
people would start spamming tomatoes
brutal
oh so um
hang on let me just send my order
okay done
did you guys order
i
will right now
oh we have a new contender for worse
clickbait family
oh let me check calls let's do a call
let's take a peek i added a link
see it it in the
relates to the topic we talked about
before
oh he faked being on a wheelchair on
twitch
oh yeah
this is amazing yeah yeah it's like a
infamous video performs a miracle
it says
did this guy get cancelled after this or
what oh yeah big time he's like
permanently balanced which that's oh did
he get twitch actually stepped in
yeah yeah and he tried to come back
recently and then he got to perma band
again oh
and was he popular at the time he did
this
yeah pretty popular yeah whoa
an [ __ ] so this i remember this story
he was in a wheelchair
he was you know
he was uh pretending to be
uh crippled
yeah
why why would you pretend to be crippled
for donations he got donations for new
wheelchairs operations and stuff so he
was acting this was a long scheme
uh disabled by the way not crippled
um [ __ ] cripples considered offensive
nowadays okay i'm sorry sorry i'm
swedish nope that's my apology i'm
learning every day i am i know you
didn't mean anything by it but yeah
generally nope thank you for correcting
me uh disabled
um
so um he so what was the long con though
because if he was popular on twitch how
was it that he was like oh any money for
a new wheelchair and all that [ __ ]
like well i guess he wasn't that popular
he was a decently big streamer
so he he figured by pretending to be
disabled he could get more donations and
stuff
and he did yeah interesting
so here is him performing a miracle
hey angel hi everybody already leave
yeah mongol had to go
mission
[Music]
oh and she was like trying to distract i
think we actually watched this on the
show yeah i remember this now
that twitch has a long history of people
faking illnesses oh man
let me go back this this is a how did
they [ __ ] up so bad
i think he thought his camera was off i
know but it's like you got the number
one rule don't don't get out of the
wheelchair
don't start jerking off if there's a
camera in front of you
this is even worse man
don't have to think about it dude
i'm back
[Music]
oh my god
like to the fish shop today because
she's freaking out right now like going
out and meeting new people we constantly
have to take him to like oh god she
knows it's over he left the chair there
too the gravy train is over i left the
chair there he's gonna shut off the
stream
because like we love talking to the
people there anyways girl you are
bye-bye bye-bye i hope you enjoyed the
gravy train that came in
just like in this huge flow and you got
scared and like came inside on my lap
and i was like oh this is so cute like
he's cuddling with me because he's
scared
he stands off he took a leak on my lap
oops
bye bye bye bye
that's a great one
so we're talking about um
oh it's gonna take a call let's see
has a joke to make me laugh what do you
guys think
been waiting for over a year
all right let's give selena a chance
been waiting a year to tell one joke i
think i think i need to correct
something oh apparently he was disabled
at one point but he
uh prolonged it someone said in the in
super shot so he was disabled but he was
he just kept it going because it was
advantageous to him okay interesting
sorry for getting that wrong
fair enough okay so this girl selena has
been waiting a year to make ethan laugh
because we haven't done it you know
so selena that second episode now is
your opportunity
to make ethan laugh
are you ready how are you feeling
um
well
uh it's not necessarily to make you
laugh i was gonna call in then
now i don't know if it'll even hit
um
but it's a good joke for people to know
so but you you've been waiting a year
so this better be good yeah
okay
i have three jokes
i say what
i have three jokes do i have time for
all of them
three jokes she's saying you have three
jokes okay well you have one minute
that's the rule
right i think you got uh yeah here i'm
gonna i'm gonna set up a timer so you're
gonna have to you have to get one minute
i mean uh so you kind of decide how you
wanna deliver the content
my fingers on the drop button
ready all right selena i'll count you
down here we go you have one minute
ethan laugh here we go
in three two one begin
what's the difference between a dirty
bus station and a lobster with a boob
job
one's a busty crustacean and the other
is a crusty bus station
[Applause]
nothing
did it i i don't know
ethan did not laugh
you still have 30 seconds if you'd like
to try one of the other two jokes
i have another one but it kind of fell
it's regarding michael jackson i'm not
sure if i can say it on air
what do you think
i don't know but you're eating into your
time you have 10 seconds
okay
what do a silver medalist and michael
jackson have in common
they both came in a little behind
that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up and and you delivered
it right at the minute mark
that's foul
did you laugh though i mean you might
you kind of huh i guess she got i guess
she got me at the end yeah i wasn't
prepared to laugh at that
but i guess you got me
so what does that mean i mean we used to
have rules about i don't want to i'm not
rewarding that joke okay we're not
really not joking i'm sorry with peace
yeah you waited a year for that yeah
the first joke i didn't understand why
you waited i mean that seemed kind of
like a jokey joke book kind of joke
it is but like
i mean it's a nice icebreaker for people
to
to have you know to have in your memory
it's easy to memorize
and it usually lands as people when
we're looking for jokes
got it
selena do you think michael jackson's
innocent or guilty
oh i won't comment on that i don't want
to offend ap
she knows the show yeah av knows how i
feel about it well i liked your joke
abey did you like her joke
uh yeah
he likes the joke
well selena thank you you made me laugh
what can i say ken came in a little
behind that's what you call silver
medals
gaming
got horrible
shame on you selena but thank you for
the call
all right peace and love peace and love
peace and love
kind of took me by surprise that second
one
was the first one was so clean yeah
exactly and then we went uh
the opposite direction for number two
she did it though she did it
uh she wants to share a fun
uh show love to dan
drop
what don't need people calling and
showing love to dan
to me someone says she wants to call in
and show love to dan
no
yeah
somebody's interested in that
dan get that mayo
boyfriend and her have a two-month-old
baby it's been a strain on the
relationship oh that sounds horrible
keep romance alive um
i think you're gonna i'll talk to this
person a little bit but brooke i'm
brooke okay so
so brooke you are a new mom 23
you guys have a two-month-old baby and
you have a strain on your relationship
uh you said how do i keep romance alive
is that the issue that you're having
between your husband or boyfriend
yeah i just figured that you would have
some advice on how you and ela kept your
relationship not necessarily romance
alive but just how you navigated the
the initial
first because the hard the hard part is
the beginning where you're having no
sleep you know and it's just really been
stressful and we've been fighting more
than we ever did
three baby you know
how was your boyfriend or husband
he's one year younger than me so he's 22
and i'm 23. okay so you guys are pretty
young
yes we are
so what's your routine like uh what's
your who takes care of the baby what's
their what's your guys's schedule
i think that's probably the root of the
issue is that i'm home all day
and that means
you know the taking care of the baby
taking care of everything in the
household and i also work from home and
so i'm balancing all that while he goes
to work at
a like a physical job
and so when he gets home he wants to
relax and i want you know a break and so
we just kind of argue over well whose
turn is it
got it
that's tough i think do you feel that he
doesn't appreciate like what you're
doing at home enough
yeah i feel like if maybe there was more
appreciation then i wouldn't be so
offended and i would
i wouldn't mind taking on more of the
responsibilities but because it seems
like
all of my
hard work is overlooked it's really
frustrating and we both have been
snapping really easily
yeah i i
and what does your boyfriend do
he works in like a store stock room at
the back of a retail store
okay
so
i totally understand the situation dude
those first times are so tough and i
think one thing that your boyfriend may
not understand
is that the work at home
is so [ __ ] hard dude and i can't
imagine that you're taking care of the
house
as well as the baby it's just
um the stress and the amount of work is
is unbelievable and i'm assuming when
the baby wakes up in the middle of the
night to feed that that's on you as well
right
oh absolutely he is the deepest sleeper
and i have to physically shake him if i
want help so i'm just running on low
sleep and my patience is up most of the
time yes you're probably not even
getting like a good chunk of sleep
throughout the day for maybe just one
maybe a few hours at a time right when
the baby's sleeping
yeah just a few hours a day for sure
that's tough
what does he what is he so stressed out
about because he goes to work
he has a normal job i mean i understand
work stuff but does he help out with the
baby at all
he does when i ask
and i just feel like i shouldn't have to
give direction and ask
all the time
i see
so i
so what's happening is that you're
resentful
because of all the work you're doing and
he doesn't appreciate
but the thing is
i think what's causing the problem is
that your resentment is now making you
out of like
not wanting to ask your boyfriend for
help even though he's willing to help
when you ask but sometimes i think with
the boyfriend he he's such a young man
and he's working he probably doesn't
know what to do or how to help a lot of
times
so i don't think you should feel like oh
i don't want to have to ask i feel like
that comes from
the resentment and that might be a lot
of times where the problem is because
he's willing to help but in your mind
you're like i don't want to have to ask
so then you get bitter because you're
not asking him for help
and so you get more mad
and
even though i don't understand what i'm
saying like i feel like there's there's
this disconnect between you guys there
where i think you should feel okay
asking him for help if he's willing to
help
yeah that makes a lot of sense i
definitely it's very equal fault like i
don't want people to think that i'm
trashing him or anything i love him he's
amazing but i think
i just get
i definitely get a bad attitude like you
were saying
um yeah and i get that because
you're what you're doing is so people
really you can't understand unless
you've had a kid it's so hard and it's
so much work and like you know i had
help i had family members
me and eva were both
not even working at the time of of uh
theodore's uh when he was really young
like your baby is
and it's just unbelievable
amount of stress and work so i
understand your train of thought where
you're like i'm stressed i shouldn't
even have to ask him right and that
makes sense to me because it's fueled by
your frustration but i think if you
could just try to remember that he
is
probably doesn't know how to help and
probably needs the direction so if you
can just try to get rid of that
frustration and asking him if you could
just learn to
ask him and tell him what you need from
him that that would help a lot
yeah i'll definitely just take a deep
breath and try to do it from a loving
place and not
not be so angry about it for sure
yeah but
but you guys will get through it you
guys are in like the really hard times
you know and uh
it's normal
you know it's it's hard it's hard it's
normal and it's hard so
thank you for that
for listening all right brooke you guys
will be all right all right
thank you all right take care
bye
i'm about to be in baby world myself
here soon
right how
how far out is it
at the beginning of february
oh okay so it's still a ways away
because she's not really showing it's
crazy like i don't it's like it'd be
like
yeah i uh i mean i noticed her bump last
week yeah i feel like that was like the
first time yeah that i've really noticed
that she's showing i can't believe we're
about to have another baby more poop for
you to eat alfredo
more snacks you guys uh
find out the gender this week next week
it's next week okay
cool you keep saying you know it's a
girl
or you think we don't know i think it's
a girl yeah that'd be cool
i feel bad so bad for brooke i gather
that there's not much family or anybody
in the picture to help and like without
help having a baby is so [ __ ] hard
you guys i i can't i mean i don't have a
kid so i i literally don't know um
but
i think back to myself at 24 years old
22 he's 22. oh she's 23. oh and she's
23. yeah
yeah even worse yeah right even harder i
think back to like the person that i was
at that age
um having to handle that responsibility
on top of working and everything else i
mean
i yeah i mean
kudos to her for handling as well as she
is yeah that's tough tough tough tough
i i got a private message from the
person that said they wanted to give me
props
and they
they invented the system they said i am
calling in to give you kudos for all
your positive pig comments as a pig mom
i appreciate it that's a [ __ ] simp
shout out to uh
rainbow gun drops
rainbow come drops
gumdrops
not gumdrops that's disgusting nobody
said gumdrops
she says she has three pet pigs
i i feel like i would i kind of want a
pet pig i actually really would love a
pet pig they seem really great pets
they get so big
some some do yeah even the small ones
get huge yeah they're all pigs
yeah like you get they they sell these
like little cute little uh teacup pigs
or whatever they call them yeah but they
actually get [ __ ] enormous yeah for
sure they're small when they're babies
yeah it's it's you know
they get about as big as a large dog you
know what i mean i wonder if they could
sleep in your bed and stuff
or like go upstairs and all that go
upstairs for sure um yeah i had a friend
who had two pet pigs um and they were so
sweet really yeah
yeah they seem like they do actually
make really good really good pets
it seems interesting
you can talk to a pet mom if you want
i don't know if maybe we dropped the
call i'm not sure
uh what do you got here love you got
something for me oh yeah i mean a couple
accidentally adopted a 650 pound mini
pig oh my god that's what i'm saying
they sell these quote mini pigs and they
ain't that [ __ ] mini look how big
this thing is
also was it take to feed a pig that size
you know you've got a problem that that
thing is a teaser
we got esther cute look how cool old
friend of mine on facebook if i was
interested
i love it 70
i worry this music might be copyrighted
which is unfortunate because i want to
hear what they're saying
the very next day everything changed
it was so cute like a little dog like oh
my god i love him
little babe ass looking big yeah
yeah i'm worried about the uh
he opens the door what a ledge bruh what
the [ __ ] dude they're super smart
they're extremely smart animals these
are crazy open the door with his snout
yeah
cute
legend
but for real oh what the [ __ ] you got a
bean bag
no way
no way can you potty train a pig must be
right
i remember talking to the girl i knew
about that specifically i to be honest i
don't i don't remember how can you live
in a house with a giant pig that just
shits and pisses inside it's impossible
oh god he opens the fridge
oh my god dude that's one cool [ __ ]
pig yeah i agree
so they told this guy the pig would be
70 pounds and it grew to 650.
oh
wow
how long do pigs live
how long do pigs live
fifteen to twenty years
till a little bit more
if you want you can't potty train them
books
with a litter box that's pretty amazing
that's
that's dope
that's better than
than with the dog
the cat level potty training
yeah i can guarantee you if i had a pet
pig i probably would never eat pork
again
yeah that'd be
that'd be wrong get this sweet boy
can you try to unmute it let's see if
it's still going
there you go
damn it
can you really copyright that just
someone going like bling if it's a
well-known song it might i i don't
recognize it but
yeah i'm not sure let's watch um
okay so wait you someone found potential
contender for worst
family vlog clickbait more than
the prince family
yeah
so who is this she got diagnosed with
cancer and it's click bait
you [ __ ] kidding me
are you serious
yep
ian's fine yeah you didn't found this
they totally lied about this someone in
the discord discord
sentences okay that's apparently their
daughter in this picture they changed
this thumbnail
they clickbaited her dot their daughter
getting cancer yep
that's what i read yeah
[Laughter]
and the yeah they changed the thumbnail
now
[Music]
thank you zach
[Laughter]
yo
that is bad [ __ ] karma
no dude so wait this is the channel
um
um
are you sure that they they turned the
labrant
wait they have 13 million dude these
family channels are crazy 13 million
subs like i never even heard of these
[ __ ]
the lebran they got 50 million views on
their wedding video
oh did they disappear
no they're here they still out here she
got diagnosed with cancer one week ago
three million views you better not be
[ __ ] with me i'm going to lose my
damn mind
i mean the likes are overwhelming so
yeah
are you guys sure did anyone watch this
yeah well so in the dogs there's a time
stamp to the part where they're like oh
she doesn't have cancer oh okay okay
but hold on it seems like she's getting
treated for it like she's bawled in
what the [ __ ] is going on
here's the time
stamp bad i was truly just riddled with
anxiety i had convinced myself that our
two-year-old daughter had had cancer and
it sounds so blunt and so
almost bad to say but i was convinced
and
i i really i wasn't eating i couldn't
sleep um she had bruising on her legs
like most kids do but as you google
things you can just convince yourself of
stuff and that's my
[Music]
dude made a whole documentary because he
googled that she had bruises on her legs
personality what am i missing how does
this get three million views and and
like overwhelming likes that's a great
question really didn't talk to anybody
about it no that's the thing so i think
it was like
eating him up inside too just like only
talking to me about it who i talked to a
doctor about it i was like taking all
the weight for him because i was like no
it's fine because i feel like i had to
be that way because if we were both the
way what the [ __ ] happened to us which
is what i feel
and i kept justifying reasons why this
was going to happen to us because of our
faith or maybe because of our following
and to
go through this battle on social media
you know you justify reasons why maybe
bad things are supposed to happen to you
yeah um and pojo was waking up in the
middle then it didn't happen though
yeah i i literally wasn't eating i got
this bro why is it all about you dude
let's talk about your daughter damn we
knew exactly what god was doing for the
family and i was like god
i gotta do something only god can enable
a family to be this trashy that's all it
was
by the power of god
you know keep scrolling past it
yo is this for real what the [ __ ] is
this video instagram explorer pages is
filled with kids with cancer and
different families with cancer hey man
so the rest of it is him going and
filming like actual kids with cancer and
talking to families and stuff oh
that's what the footage was yeah
yeah and i mean there's articles about
them getting backlash but um she they
titled it she got diagnosed with cancer
that is so [ __ ] and y'all still liking
this video is absolutely blowing my
[ __ ] mind these people are people of
god apparently
uh i guess i mean again i had never
heard of
it's so crazy how many people are like
this big on youtube that you just like
the lebrance if they're not i've heard
of the brand it's not in your algorithm
and so you just never hear about them i
think you used to be a tick tocker i
mean not a tick tocker a uh
viner
who like you know videos of him dancing
with his shirt off
and then i think they've gotten some
other controversy i'm looking into it
now where they were clickbaiting
something like their house was on fire
or something ridiculous jesus i love how
it goes my faith i wasn't i didn't have
no faith in god that's where my daughter
got cancer and he's like no my
daughter's fine let me go look at these
other kids who clearly didn't have
enough faith
i did have enough faith there's these
other [ __ ] bags that didn't stop it
bro you're such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
dog how dare you show other kids
[ __ ] kids with cancer so you could
clickbait a video you sick
[ __ ] twisted freak
how dare you bro you said look into them
do a content court i'm for real
yeah sounds like it
man hey man
yo
they literally clickbaited her daughter
having she got diagnosed with cancer so
this isn't even a picture of her
daughter their daughter
this is someone else's kid yeah
i'm not sure
that looks like him though with the mask
right and this is the updated thumbnail
the original thumbnail had like them as
a family together can someone find the
original thumbnail yeah you pulled it up
earlier it's in the dock oh oh oh is
that is that imgur link oh oh okay so
wait this was the original thumbnail oh
i see i thought you said this was was
was changed no that's the original
thumbnail and they that's something we
blurred their faces right
that wasn't their thumbnail we blurred
their faces this was found off someone
making a commentary thing about it
oh okay so they may have so they did so
he did show his daughter and say she got
diagnosed with cancer i'm about to
[ __ ] flip the table oh jesus this is
so [ __ ] up bro how dare you
dare you how is the like ratio so good
get the [ __ ] out that really is shocking
also like you're making money off this
are you gonna donate every [ __ ] thing
that you make from this to like
st jews or something they may i doubt it
why would you clickbait it to begin with
okay let's read the
see if i mean
let's just not say that without knowing
i mean let's go to the description yeah
i was truly just
this talking explains the health scare
we had
we praise god
that she is okay
but not all parents received the same
good news
we felt
we felt so led
to help share the stories of these three
families and help awareness
and get attention of government leaders
who can increase the paid
pediatric cancer research budget to more
than four percent
i mean i don't see anything about
donating
someone watch someone watch the
beginning and see if these [ __ ]
donated
also tell me if there's ads on it
man
i'm disgusted
regardless you can't clickbait your kid
having cancer dude that's just not okay
well there are ads on it but
isn't that because of youtube's new
policy
didn't they change it where all videos
potentially have ads no no even if you
don't monetize it no what are you
talking about oh i thought they updated
that
no no
i'm still a rookie
now they update it so if you have a
children's audience then it like uh you
can't
um target
kids
you can't target kids that's it because
there's like laws against it
gotcha here they are uh describe how
they prayed the cancer away oh for real
they're taking credit for it it's
awesome
wait no
unfortunately those other families
didn't pray hard enough sick kid
why
why i can't even begin to fathom the
weight that these parents must feel
every second of every day
you know what the cause is good right
like the cause is good childhood cancer
is just so [ __ ] it breaks my heart i
hate it terrible yeah of course like the
cause is good i like the i like this i
just don't know how they are okay with
this
that to me is just
i mean with the yeah i mean that's just
that title combined with the original
thumbnail is just unforgivable yeah
unbelievable pretty awful i mean with
the existing
thumbnail there's still obviously the
implication that it's somebody in their
family but
but you could say they're they're
referring to
some other little girl
but yeah that original thumbnail is
that's pretty bad so here let's let's
see them pray that
that is why it is so essential to us
that as people of faith we prayed over
and lay hands on these kids these
families believing in people of faith
laying hands on kids you never heard
that one before
[Applause]
thank you thank you i'll be here all
week
but at the end of the day to do what
only he can do
we're thankful for doctors thankful for
medicine and medical advancements
through the years
someone saying this guy tweeted about
losing his virginity when he got married
or something sounds funny
it's a country just to bring these kids
good vibes
we come knowing that the same god who
brought sarah's womb back to life to
have isaac
who opened someone is saying a kid
behind the camera has some great click
bait i'm not really familiar with them
ice who called the lame to walk who
healed the leper who made the sun stand
still who created everything we see and
fills our lungs with every breath who
rose jesus from the dead defeating sin
what the [ __ ] am i watching shut up dude
you clickbaited your daughter with
having cancer you don't act all high and
mighty
owen cook self-help oh no hey let's
let's watch some i want to watch the um
cut videos i love that [ __ ] by the way i
do
i do see uh some people
disagreeing about saying that abu
is right about youtube starting to put
ads on monetized videos
it's called right to monetize yeah um oh
so they'll monetize your videos yeah and
you won't get paid but they'll still put
an ad on wait when does that happen
uh the articles that i'm seeing about it
were all from the end of last year but
why don't they do it like under what
situation
um even if you're not part of the
partner program
oh okay here's an article in forbes
youtube will now show ads on all videos
even if the creators don't want them
but the real story is if you're not part
of the creator program they'll put ads
on your video that makes sense
right if you're part of the partner
program they'll pay you you'll get paid
right yeah
that makes sense because you're not
in
the youtube partner program you won't
receive a share of the revenue from
these ads right yeah i mean they
probably get so much traffic from
unpartnered videos and stuff that you
know make sense from business standpoint
right not mad about that
it does mean we can't judge people
anymore though these people are in the
part these people are yeah obviously yes
so that doesn't apply to them very true
so here we got some cut videos i want to
watch
um body count people rank most
attractive
uh oh
was there one that uh okay let's do most
attractive least attractive kind of like
that premise
this is sad this feels mean doesn't it i
guess it has a lot of views
you guys have any um opinion on which
one i should watch
uh
[Music]
here should we take a vote a poll
body count
i just feel bad judging people based on
uh attractiveness but okay it's the
premise of the video right so [ __ ] it
let's do it you look like thor had kids
and became a dad i'm thor's kid no no
you're a thor okay who just let himself
go
[Music]
my name is chris i'm an anthropologist i
also work here at cut my name is molly
murphy i'm a tax
[Laughter]
are you guys comfortable with this doing
the rating thing or you don't want
people are saying body count yeah let's
do body count yeah
also by the way uh our food is going to
be here in a minute oh you're trying to
get who you
let's think body count yeah
there was also like guess who's the cop
that looked kind of funny
who's the narc
all right body count let's go we did
that earlier here on the crew
oh really yeah maybe
you know what you guys say that but i
have proof and i was just trying to
cover but you know after overthinking it
i don't know if i want to now
everybody
about who got the strawberries oh my god
no please shut up about the strawberries
for god's sake
all right let's do who's who's got the
big eyes body cat
when i was a virgin i also stood with my
feet out like this
i feel like there's
there's something there because a douche
all right who has slept
hell yeah who the [ __ ] doesn't well some
people don't but yeah i like sex yeah
that haircut is probably i've never seen
a haircut like that in my whole life who
slept oh wait a minute go back
did you see that guy again you like zach
i straight up thought that was a hat
like something nothing happened that's
his hair right yeah whoa yeah for sure
that is a unique one i don't know that
that kind of hair is gonna pull too much
tail listen who the [ __ ] doesn't well
some people don't but yeah i like sex
i'm not exactly a max
people i'm so excited are you nervous at
all yes
as someone who is not very sexually
experienced i feel like i might not have
a great read so i'm going to try i
apologize
so everybody gave us their numbers
beforehand okay so you're not guessing
you're assigning numbers got it here we
go
zero oh there's a virgin in here oh wow
okay okay who's the virgin
i'm a guest
you know it's got to be the dude in the
blue
it's too obvious i do obviously yeah i'm
that's like i mean obvious sometimes is
the way it is yeah perhaps
i gotta hear more i think it's this
homie or this homie it could be a girl
too a little twist
okay
21.
35 okay these keep going up oh yeah we
got some experienced players in here i
mean i want to be friends with this
person
there's someone in there with 50 how is
that even possible these guys are way
too young to have those numbers like
let's say it's this guy this guy looks
like maybe he's 30 at most i mean how
many people you have to [ __ ]
1500
there's no way
how many people like okay let's say you
start you're you've been sexually active
for 10 years
so what is 10 years divided by
1500 like how much is that per that's
like
a hundred per year or just over a
hundred per year
so you're looking at ten people per
month for
ten years
they're getting out there partying and
all i guess i guess i don't know that's
disgusting though
is that right i mean it's only 10.10 per
month it seems like it'd be way crazier
than that
wait you're saying over the course of 10
years
150
per year divided by 12 12.5 per month
i mean i guess it's possible it's doable
12.5 per month just a lot that's like
four per
week the logistics just don't make sense
it just doesn't make sense
in terms of dating or even if you're
just hooking up what if they're uh sex
worker their what what if it's their job
yeah sure maybe they're a performer that
would make sense porn stars that's the
only way that makes sense yeah but even
then i don't think they have sex with
that many people new people that would
be you'd be very busy
okay but so wait we're talking about 12
per month
12.5 on average yeah it's 12 per month
divided by
you know 4.2 weeks in a month so what
does that come out to
2.9 let's round up to three so three per
week three a week
that's not
when you put it like that i don't know
per week i mean if you're deadly and
that means some weeks are going to be
slower right and some weeks are going to
be more you're here
i don't know
whoa whoa
very nice
all right you call out your first person
when you're ready
all right so what's good bro come on up
here
what's your relationship status man i'm
single you're single as
did you go to college i did you have a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or i had a
girlfriend for three years three years
okay did you cheat on her no
i didn't blackman don't cheat
wait he said what don't you black man
yeah moving along i don't think you're a
virgin but you're not
too high i'm going to give you a three
yeah that's three yeah you seem pretty
chill you seem like the type of person
you really want to get to know someone
yeah
he said he was a girlfriend for three
years i do like vibes yeah so i'm gonna
give you a three you're pretty solid
there
hello hi what's your name she might be a
virgin
okay you're short like me oh no i'm
looking you in the eye yes and there is
the stereotype that you know short 1500
i don't think it's fishy
which i love the one thing you can say
for certain is the person with 1500 is
most definitely a man
i don't know
[Music]
that's a man for sure
why because you think they're inflating
their numbers no because dudes are
[ __ ] disgusting
that's why i mean
that's why do you think she looks like
innocent do you think she looks freaky
man see that's the [ __ ] like you will
never [ __ ] know i know that
that's funny i know that for a fact i
feel like maybe you might be like the
bondage type
i would probably assume that you had
like a higher
30. all right why middle of the who's
ready with that the way you dress kind
of implies that you're busy i don't know
if you have time for 1500 people
entering you
or
you entering them
what's up man hmm i can't get a feel on
that girl
30 seems
high but i don't know man maybe not
what is your relationship status i am
married to my husband and i also have a
boyfriend oh [ __ ] i thought he was a
virgin i'm sorry he said he's married
and has a boyfriend this [ __ ]
[ __ ] like crazy he said it was too
obvious i told you
am i confusing is that what you know
this guy's a player
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god this guy's high up there damn
i don't think you're the 1500 one why
don't you think i'm at 1500 oh cause
he's doing orgies that could explain the
1500s he's the 1500 i'm guessing
that makes sense
the orgy i haven't considered the orgy
factor oh i think we just i just went
from virgin to 1500
but it's west
well you can't judge just from the look
the 1500 person might be someone who
could attract anyone i think maybe
you're someone that would attract a
smaller subset of people oh dude
nope that guy goes to the right or he's
getting [ __ ]
no this guy this guy could totally pull
1500
if he's out there swinging oh yeah i'm
gonna go with 21. i'm gonna go for it
he's gonna get this one 21 the guy just
told you he's had a foursome
do the math dude yeah
i think he's the fifth married too
though he said with a boyfriend
he said he's married with a boyfriend
oh
got it yeah yeah
that didn't collect the first time
[Laughter]
my man's
slang in that pipe man i think so
too hello hey what's your name okay how
old are you bro 22 22. i don't look like
it do i no you look like you like 12 bro
[Applause]
what does your partying look like one
yeah
i think his virgin too why no one asking
about his relationship status or they're
cutting it out to keep it mysterious
yeah i mean this is all
there's nothing wrong with that number
but i can just tell like you don't have
your rhythm yet
i think you're a virgin when i was a
virgin i also stood with my feet out
like this
i feel like there's
there's something there i think my man's
is in the lows i'm gonna say you got
three though man what's the status
they cut out the status that's making me
think this guy's a virgin
how many tattoos do you have probably
like 16 or 17. okay you stopped counting
yeah so you're not 1500. because that
person did not stop counting so what's
your relationship status i am currently
engaged engaged oh [ __ ] so like you guys
do threesomes yeah
wait wait wait wait wait
would you i mean
no no offense
why not she and i have not explored a
threesome with another woman yet i'm
gonna come oh whoa i'm gonna give you
the number 30.
donald trump calm down chill donnie keep
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
chill i'm gonna come keep hey hey dad
that was not there man not me
thank you come on come on somebody
bringing reasons yes thank you it seems
like a reasonable number having
adventured on both sides of the line
there
how you feeling how are you really good
good what is it that you do i'm in
entertainment world so acting modeling
motherfucker's a porn star
because there's got to be one of them
there's got to be one
well i mean the orgy factor uh but he
says that entertainment side okay what
do you mean
they didn't show it yeah he's does porn
you're in the entertainment well you
think if he slept with 1500 people we
would have seen one of us would
recognize him
yeah right
i feel like that means a lot of people
are after you yeah i mean you've had sex
let's just be frank you've done it
i feel like maybe absolutely
but i feel like you also seem kind of
reserved you're confident you're tall
and you're dark [ __ ] i mean who the [ __ ]
don't want
me what about now
what's the same
oh man them glasses ain't falling
hello
what's your name i'm jasmine hi jasmine
you are so pretty i think i have a crush
on you what do you do for work i'm an
exotic dancer are you partnered up no a
free bird how long have you been a free
bird uh a couple years i was married
before that do you have any kinks i'm
into bondage forceful play asmr yeah you
have a lot of cases yeah i would
consider myself adventurous this was
good what number i have zero and 30. i
gotta give you 30 because you definitely
[ __ ]
you were married
i mean you were married well thank you
it was nice meeting you oh good meeting
you this guy's trying to hit it
what's your name michaela how old are
you 19. 19.
i was freaky at 19.
what's your number left it's [ __ ]
zero
she might be zero i could
for marriage maybe that's something that
my [ __ ] dumbass didn't think of
apparently you've slept with 1500 people
was blank what number would you put on
it two
yeah
how was that it was fun and
[ __ ] kind of weird uh with a show of
hands uh who did sam get correct
nobody
oh wow
holy [ __ ] yeah that's our dude fifteen
hundred how are you feeling that mother
damn
wow
i called it though i told you to be a
dude man i don't know that that's like
come on
look at him
you did it dude
what kind of [ __ ] is this
zero yeah no surprises there
all right okay
so let's have everybody switch to their
number
[Music]
[Applause]
okay 51. hold me on the left [ __ ] damn
that girl's 60 okay
it's all
yeah
yeah sir know holy [ __ ]
all right let's call him out hey what's
his number what did i originally guess
you guys three
three i was
a newbie at the time yeah not get it so
do you want to explain your number a
little bit more um it just kind of
happened organically i guess the hot
streak number was like 30 30 and how
long like a year when do you think 52 is
coming
i have no idea i believe sex is like an
organic thing so hopefully sooner than
later
hello
sixty yep okay
so you have your way
my back is covered in bruises from a
fetish night oh my god
dan called it dad knew that that girl
was
wild
i didn't see it at first but now i see
it yep her back is covered and bruised
holy [ __ ] can i sign up for this [ __ ] i
mean
yeah you know getting a number this high
is not that hard because my line in
college was hey i'm trying to sleep with
everyone on my dorm floor do you want to
go back to my place
oh my goodness holy [ __ ] how do you
define sex like for me this is every
activity i've done with somebody with
the intent of an orgasm whether there
was one or not okay so not always
penetrative correct and i came like came
up sexually during the aids crisis so
like we were all about hand jobs and
blow jobs would you recommend for people
to have more sexual partners i think
it's good the more experienced people
are sexually the better they are at
having it and the better sex everyone is
happening the happier we all are all
right
noted dude what the zero's like noted
bro
what's up bruh
i'm saving myself you saving yourself
for that ring i'm sure do you ever have
temptation yeah obviously it would be
abnormal yeah like do you think i'm cute
yeah
really insecure she's hitting on
everyone
she has someone else like would you have
sex would you invite me
turn you on yeah
don't ask questions you don't want
answers to any doubts about that like
wanting to break free from that
no i've been following my culture and it
i think i'm pretty confident about it
all right making sure burger's nice out
of here
he gave me 51 i'm 21. i didn't come out
as lesbian until i had been having a lot
of straight sex for almost 20 years the
first woman i had sex with we were both
having our first lesbian experience
terrible idea yeah it was terrible she
cried that happened to me with my first
threesome with two girls one of them
started crying and then she told us she
had a boyfriend and i was like what are
you doing
i keep cheating and also you might be
gay like
how wrong was i about your number yeah
so you gave me double you know what i
mean are you like submitted to anybody
or what yeah no i'm single for sure and
i'm i've turned out a lot at some point
you start to understand as a man
especially uh your worst that's all it
is hello yeah no you're worried
appreciate that i feel like this is a
pretty decent number yeah all right i'm
over it
i mean i get it we got that we got the
answer
the mystery solved yeah that was fun
that 1500 reveal was the one everyone's
waiting for
my dude
they got you that was right right out of
the gate you were like it's this dude
for sure with the zero oh
these videos are way too entertaining to
watch so these cuts
should we do one more
oh my god the chat is going so [ __ ]
fast how am i supposed to read this
when you don't look at it for a while
should we do body counts of us
no
no no how long we've been going for uh
three hours
is the food here
i believe so
oh well then we're going to the foods
here baby
um women matches man to their tinder
profile oh because the picture looks so
different is that what the premise is
let's watch this one i'm confused on the
premise though
oh just
clean up nice
this is some [ __ ] i would post like as a
joke you with the tattoos come here
[Music]
yeah the dating stuff is always
i'm like was married
before this whole dating world
so all this stuff is pretty interesting
and alien to me
hi do you use dating apps i used to any
success i kind of had fun with it i
think it's like an easier way to meet
people because nowadays like no one
wants to talk to people in real life we
have eight men that are coming out here
you're going to match the dating profile
to the person oh gee what are some
stereotypes of men's profiles that
you've seen there's the gym rat i think
this one seems kind of boring let me
let me go to their channel and sort by
popular
there's got to be better ones
let's see
oh yeah some of these are super graphic
what the hell
there's one called match the joke to the
person
oh
that's interesting
centered in this court if you want
this one's really high too
teachers guess who's high
but i like the job let's match jobs
match the job
let's match the job
give me a good spin
how my house is on fire
yeah brittany is a firefighter for sure
[Music]
hello hi i'm timmy rogar i'm a drag
queen and a bartender my name is wait
they're telling me alexander i'm milo
dizon i am crystal reed and i work here
at cut do you love what you do i [ __ ]
love what i do like a dream job totally
he said it's a bartender a dumber way to
make money do you know why you're here
i'm sorry to drag something oh oh oh
dress guessing you're gonna match a job
to person okay am i gonna have like a
list to choose from we're gonna give you
a little list
[Music]
a dude just comes out dresses the
mandalorian
bounty hunter wait what the [ __ ] a
horse listener
that's not a profession
well how dare you i have it clearly it
is i'm here saying because you haven't
heard of it
saying
horse
today now
horse listener is not a [ __ ] horse as
i'm reading it i don't understand it
what the horse listener this is what
google says the term horse whisperer
well so is that the same thing no they
listen they don't whisper they listen
bro
um
it's all that ivermetron dude
a horse whisperer can help traumatized
horses to trust humans again but that's
a whisper
subtract
whisper
i don't want to hear about whispers
you're probably going to tell us in the
show
uh that's a really good point love i
think we're probably like five seconds
away from them
what does a horse listener do i do
donkey shows and uh tijuana
there's a book called
horse lessener
some of these jobs i didn't know
were real jobs whenever you're ready all
right do you want to come up first
nice to meet you great meeting you it's
a good handshake thank you do you shake
a lot of hands at work
i do
give me one more good one
okay can i touch you you should yeah you
should okay do you feel okay i'm i'm
okay with it okay wait let me see your
fingers
no you can't be the firefighter i really
just want to get rid of territ reader
i don't know what that is you know like
the psychic arrow how do you feel about
god
uh he's a cool guy can you sing like a
gospel thing i'll give you a beat
go ahead
i'm sorry i can't sleep
i don't okay i'm going with pastor i
feel good about pastor because you
failed all the tests i think
i think you're a software engineer oh
man so this is literally just what
you're labeled as forever now i know man
okay next
oh you're definitely a horse listener
whatever that is from nature
maybe she might be the porn producer
is that a bad thing no it's not it's
just like it's versus what i would have
thought you know like a heavier set guy
who breathes heavy like
do you like what you do i love what i do
i want you to do a little motion of like
brushing a horse
okay
okay not very good have you ever ridden
a horse before i have you're a horse
listener for sure what about how many
horses have she really firefighters oh
wait okay everyone says she's horseless
and then she got tarot card reader like
what the [ __ ] did they cut out
they literally gave her tarot card
reader well this girl did
they all
rate they all take turns i don't think
so i think they all wear the same uh
what the [ __ ] do i know [ __ ] do you know
that's how the last one worked do you
work with a lot of people yes
do you like people
some do you know cpr i am certified in
cpr what's your favorite porn genre
anime
what
oh
let's go
[ __ ] yeah
damn
dude no way you're a porn producer this
is the trick
she's not a porn producer well maybe she
is
what is the trick what's your favorite
book i like to read reference so like
studying new topics you're hard
i think
i wish i wish i could see the job one
okay she's definitely a porn producer
can i go a software engineer i'm gonna
go tear it reader i still barely know
what it is
i'm gonna go terry reader for sure
wait before
teach me your ways with makeup oh my god
you smell neutral i smell nothing
because you have good style i would say
you're a bartender i think i want to go
okay we got the thank you dan with your
nurse how come because everything else
is like
it would kind of make sense i think
that's like the most thing that i
wouldn't expect you're wearing lots of
crystals i'm gonna go with tarot reader
yeah tara rita for sure
hello
fellow asian
[Laughter]
this is boring
i'm yeah i'm not feeling this one
let's go to the end and just figure out
who's here
allowed to like work this motherfucker's
a tarot raider this guy's a pastor
firefighter okay that makes sense she's
she's the horse listener the anime girl
er nurse
software engineer
tara reader
this girl's a bounty hunter [ __ ] dude
she does look kind of badass
scary not surprising
bartender okay wow who gives a [ __ ]
yeah you got to feel a little lame being
the guy who's a bartender you got a
[ __ ] horse listener right there
all right we'll find a better one for
next time
so guys with that being said what a
treat it's been h3tv forever and ever
um and ever
there is a fruit fly on my desk oh i got
it nice
bye
that's fruity yeah idiot
so um thanks everyone for watching
thanks everybody who called in thanks
everyone for calling calls today h3tv i
love h3tv thank you everyone that
donated subscribed became a member we
love you guys so much our members
are astronomical they mean everything
they're astronomical
um
any other chats to read or are we good
i'm seeing
carly egan said my friend told me he got
ivermectin prescribed for his dog i told
him to lock that [ __ ] up tight q anons
are frothing to have it yeah that's for
sure or just south
i mean the remark on that's got to be
good
you know stockx ivermectum
super recommend googling amazon web
service terms and conditions and reading
section 42.10
what is that
i am
you looking that up right now i am i
don't know
this is interesting
so
diamond
doesn't make sense
what
lumber yard materials
nuclear facility what the [ __ ] is this
42.1 acceptable use your use of lumber
yard materials must comply with
acceptable use policy the lumber yard
materials are not intended for use with
life critical or safety critical systems
such as use in operational medical
equipment automated transportation
yada yada nuclear facilities however
this
will not apply in the event of the
occurrence
of a widespread viral infection
transmitted via bites or contact what
the [ __ ] is this bro what do you want
keep reading
i guess weirder
however this restriction will not apply
in the events of occurrence
of a widespread viral infection
transmitted via bites or contact with
bodily fluids that causes human corpses
to reanimate
and seek to consume living human flesh
blood brain or nerve tissue and is
likely to result in the fall of
organized civilization i think it's a
joke hell yes
what
it's on there offshore yeah i was
reading it off the official website it's
in there
someone
pretty funny though
well i'll make sure when the zombie
apocalypse comes i'm gonna make sure to
go straight to amazon and
buy lumber yard materials
i'm going to use their lumber yard
murals lumber yard materials and my
nuclear facilities
hell yes i got that carve out
somebody just donated 20 super chat uh
i'm assuming [ __ ] which is really not
cool to put in a super chat man but
thank you kevin beavers he just said
[ __ ] he said super chat [ __ ]
beaver love the h3 podcast so much
thanks uh
dulce du say gonzalez so um we will be
back on um
wednesday
thursday it'll be
yeah uh it'll be up tomorrow wednesday
for members and uh thursday for
everybody else and then thursday after
dark on friday and then the new show on
sunday
baby
ready
yeah baby
all right guys have a great week we'll
see you on thursday god bless see you
guys soon
[Music]
you